GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING IF ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. ARE CALLING FOR
MEMBERS THIS IS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND ROOM
FOR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
A WEAPON TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING.
I JUST A FEW HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
FOR ALL OF YOU TO NO BEFORE WE
START. MISTER SPEAKER HAS
APPOINTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER TODD
GLORIA TO FILL IN. THE
DEMOCRATIC VACANCY PROTEST DAYS
HEARING ONLY.
WE HAVE FIFTEEN ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TO OF THOSE ARE PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT.
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY STEINORTH. AND ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY TO FORTY
NINE COOLEY.
WE'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ONCE WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT HERE'S OF
BILLS IN SIGN IN ORDER.
AND WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
NEWEST CONSULTANT ON OUR TEAM
JAMIE MACDONALD TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. AND IS ALREADY DOING SOME
GREAT THINGS FOR JIMMY WAVE TO
THE FANS.
SINCE WE OWE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND OUR FIRST BILL TODAY WILL
BE.
US USE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY TWO MISTER
LEVINE LEVINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
JOIN US.
WELCOME MR LEVINE AND GUESTS
THANK YOU FOR.
DEFYING TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM CHAIR WELCOME JIMMY AND
IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
THE.
I'M PLEASE PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY TWO WHICH WOULD WAVE
OR REDUCE ALL BUILDING PERMIT
FEES FOR SENIORS WITH A
DISABILITY WHO WANTED MAKE
ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENTS.
TO THEIR HOME. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR
OLDER ADULTS BY LOWERING COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH RENOVATING THEIR
HOUSE.
MANY OLDER ADULTS LIVE ON A
FIXED INCOME A TWENTY SEVENTEEN
GALLUP POLL SHOWED THAT MORE
THAN FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF
RETIREES DEPENDENT ON SOCIAL
SECURITY FOR A MAJORITY OF THEIR
INCOME.
FURTHERMORE TWENTY NINE PERCENT
OF.
CALIFORNIANS SIXTY YEARS AND
OLDER LIVE BELOW TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE EQUALLY IMPORTANT IS
MITIGATING THE RISK OF INJURY IN
OLDER ADULTS FALLS ARE AN
ESPECIALLY SERIOUS INJURY THAT
CAN LEAD TO COMPLICATIONS
ARISING FROM SURGERY. INFECTIONS
FROM EXTENDED CONVALESCENT
PERIODS IN NURSING HOMES OR
INCREASE RECOVERY TIMES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EASE FINANCIAL
BARRIERS TO BUILDING HOMES HOME
IMPROVEMENTS. AND REDUCE THE
RISK OF INJURY FOR SENIOR
CITIZENS THAT WILL IMPROVE THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS ELLIE
BLOCK OF EACH FRIENDLY SAUSALITO
AND THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE AND SLAMA LOCKS.
A COMMISSIONER OF THE MARIN
COUNTY COMMISSION ON AGING.
WELCOME
YOU CAN.
I AM.
RATHER CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
AND THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME ON
THE COMMISSION MARIN COUNTY
COMMISSION ON AGING.
AND UM ENABLING OLDER ADULTS TO
ADAPT TO THEIR HOME SO THEY CAN
REMAIN SAFELY IN THEM AN AGING
WHO PLACE. LOWERS THE RISK OF
INJURY FROM FALLS IS
ECONOMICALLY AT A AVERAGE AGES
AND ALLOWS CALIFORNIA ALLDERS.
STAYING GAUGE IN THE LIFE OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING THE ALSO H.
FRIENDLY SAUSALITO. THE CITY OF
SAUSALITO WITH OVER THIRTY.
POINT ONE PERCENT OF ITS
POPULATION ALREADY AGE SIXTY AND
OLDER AND BACK AND BARKED ON NH
FRIENDLY STRATEGIC PLANNING
PROCESS WITH A SURVEY OF OUR
RESIDENTS. AGE FIFTY FIVE AND
OLDER TWELVE HUNDRED SURVEYS
WERE RETURNED ONE OF THE TOP
RESULTS WITH THE CONCERN OF
THEIR BEING ABLE TO REMAIN IN
THEIR HOMES AS THEY AGE.
ALTHOUGH FULLY SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT DECLARED BEING THEM ABLE
TO REMAIN SAUSALITO AS VERY
IMPORTANT. MORE THAN HALF SAID
THE DESIGN. OF THEIR HOMES WILL
NOT MAKE IT EASY TO REMAIN ANNA.
AMONG THE SURVEY.
PARTICIPANTS SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT.
SEVENTY NINE PERCENT WERE
HOMEOWNERS AND TWENTY ONE
PERCENT WERE RENTERS.
I.
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT REPORTED
THEY LIVED ALONE ADDING TO THEIR
RISK.
AS A RESULT OF THESE FINDING AND
IN RECOGNITION OF OP THE FACT
THAT THE NUMBER ONE REASON OLDER
ADULTS INSIGHTFUL LEGAL CALL OUT
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES. IS
DUE TO THE FALLS IN THEIR HOME
ACCORDING TO SOUTHERN MARIN FIRE
DEPARTMENT THE CITY OF SAUSALITO
AS COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IN ASSOCIATION WITH
THE CITY'S AGE FRIENDLY. TASK
FORCE AND TO INTRODUCE AS H.
FRIENDLY HOME ACT ACT TATIAN
PERMIT.
GRANT PROGRAM FOR ANY AND ALL
RICHARD RESIDENTS AGE SIXTY OR
OLDER.
AND THE NEW PROGRAM AND
INITIATED IN MARCH OFFERS NO
FEE.
ARE LO FI BUILDING PERMITS
FOR HOME MODIFICATIONS LIKE
ENTRY RAMPS
HAND RAILS STAIR LIFTS WIDER
DOORWAYS NO CURB SHOWERS
ADOPTION ADJUSTABLE. HEIGHT MAP
COUNTERS AND BRACING FOR GRAB
BARS AT TIMES SHOWERS AND
TOILETS.
AMONG DOZENS OF OTHER
ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENTS
YOUNGER ADULTS.
YOU ARE ALREADY LIVING WITH A
DISABILITY ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS NEW.
.
FOR THIS NEW PROGRAM. IN THE
COUNTY OF MARIN WITH A
POPULATION OF SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS TWO
THOUSAND FORTY SEVEN SUFFERED
FOLLOW. THEIR REQUIRED EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AND TWENTY
SEVEN TING.
WHEN I AM.
WEBER PARAGRAPH. I CAN.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY TERM
PERMITS.
FEE WAIVERS.
WE'LL PUT SPOTLIGHT ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF EXCESSIVE WILL
HOME MODIFICATION FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND PROVIDE A MEANS FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
AND TOWNS.
TO PROMOTE THIS POSITIVE.
HOUSING INTERVENTION BY MAKING
IT MORE AFFORDABLE FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS TO MAKE THE
IMPROVEMENTS NECESSARY. FOR
SUCCESSFUL AND HEALTHIER AGING
IN PLACE THANK.
OKAY
SELAMA LOCKS I'M THE CHAIR OF
THE MARIN COUNTY COMMISSION ON
AGING. AND WE SEND OUR SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWENTY ONE THIRTY TWO.
THEY MARIN COUNTY COMMISSION ON
AGING IS A TWENTY THREE MEMBER
APPOINTED BY BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS AND OR CITY COUNCILS
WHO ACTIVELY REPRESENT. THEIR
COMMUNITIES
IRAN IS ONE OF THE OLDEST
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND BY
TWENTY THIRTY THREE THIRTY FOUR
PERCENT OF ITS POPULATION WILL
BE OLDER THAN SIX WILL BE SIXTY
YEARS OLD AND OLDER.
I IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
COMMISSION CONDUCTED AN OLDER
ADULT NEEDS ASSESSMENT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY. THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN OF THE
SURVEYED ADULTS WITH FALLS THE
SECOND CONCERN WAS COGNITIVE
DECLINE.
I AM A SOUTHERNER FELL RESIDENT
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
THE CITY OF SANDRA FELL HAD THE
COUNTIES LARK. HIGHEST RATE OF
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
CALLS.
WITH THE PRIMARY INJURY. COMING
FROM FALLS.
THAT NUMBER WAS SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN.
OVERALL THE COUNTY LAST YEAR.
THE RIVER THAT SHE HAD SAID TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN E. M. S.
CALLS FOR ENTRIES FROM FALLS AND
THAT WAS UP FROM THE SIXTEEN
NINETY ONE. JUST THE TWO YEARS
BEFORE.
MORE SENIORS MORE FALSE.
I'M PART OF THIS LONGEVITY
BLOOM.
I'M ALSO A REGISTERED NURSE AND
A RETIRED NAVY COMMANDER.
OUR CURRENT LAW SB THREE THIRTY.
BOB BERRYHILL TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WAVES FOR REDUCES
BUILDING PERMIT FEES FOR
VETERANS WITH SERVICE RELATED
DISABILITIES.
WE CONTEND THAT ARTS CIVILIAN
OLDER ADULTS WORKED AND SERVED
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THOSE WHO HAVE DISABILITIES
SHOULD HAVE PERMIT FEES WAIVED
OR REDUCED.
IT WAS STREAMLINED THE PROCESS
OF RETROFITTING THEIR HOMES FOR
SAFETY.
AND REDUCE FALLS AND ALLOW THEM
TO AGE IN PLACE.
IT HAS BEEN SAID NO DATA. NO
PROBLEM NO ACTION.
TODAY I HOPE YOU HAVE HEARD THE
DATA.
REALIZE THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM.
WILL HAVE POSITIVE ACTION.
AS I SAID THE COMMISSION
SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
AND EVELYN THE ADDED VALUE WOULD
INCREASE SAFE DWELLINGS FOR ALL
AGES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE
MOVE FORWARD I WOULD LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BELIEVE I'D
LIKE THEM TO HAVE DIXIE.
TO THE ROLL CALL PLEASE ADWARE
CURRY.
AB WE ARE CURRY HERE WALDRON
BLOOM CABALLERO COOLEY. COOLEY
HERE GLORIA GLORIA HERE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HERE LACKEY. LACKEY HERE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL HERE.
I WAS OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
AUDIENCE FOR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
IF YOU JUST COME FORWARD AND
JUST YOUR NAME AND IF YOU OPPOSE
OR.
SUPPORT YES PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
S. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DARRYL
CAL TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VERY AGENCIES ON
AGING.
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
AND WARRANT CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR
CALIFORNIA SINGER LEGISLATURE
AND WE DEFINITELY ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
AARON GROW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
GREAT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M WE HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS ARE
YOU WILLING TO TAKE A FEW
MINUTES.
WAS ONE AND MAKE SURE ON THEM
FOR SOMETHING ELSE FICTIVE.
YEAH.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
WE.
HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE.
I JUST WISH ALL MY WITNESSES FOR
MY BILLS WERE IS PREPARED IN
THEIR TESTIMONY AS MISS LOCKS IN
THIS BLOCK WERE.
THAT THAT MAKE THE CASE FOR.
WHAT SIZE YOU KNOW WE KNOW
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS AN AGING POPULATION?
THAT WE MUST PROTECT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CONSIDERATION AS FOR
MY VOTE.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY TO
BECAUSE I'M NOT FAR FROM ME
MAKING SURE I HAVE HAND RAILS AS
WELL SO THANKS FOR TO IN THE
BILL FOR ME.
OKAY WITHOUT OF THE FOOD YOU
COULD. TAKE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
IN RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR CURRY
AYE AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON
BLOOM CABALLERO COOLEY. COOLEY
AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
BILLS OUT SIX ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS YOU'RE WELCOME.
LIKE THE IN AND HAVE SOME
ENTERTAINING MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT.
AVOID.
HOWEVER.
MOTION AND A SECOND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
THE CONSENT.
AGUIAR CURRY AYE AGUIAR CURRY
AYE WALDRON. BLOOM CABALLERO
COOLEY COOLEY AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE.
BLOOM I.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY SIXTY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FIRST LET
ME JUST START BY ACCEPTING THE.
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE SIX
OF THE ANALYSIS.
PA AB TWENTY YEAR TWENTY SIXTY
FIVE UPDATES MY TWENTY FOURTEEN
LEGISLATION AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE WHICH IS THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT THE SURPLUS LAND ACT.
ASKED
THAT AS LOCAL AGENCIES DISPOSED
OF SURPLUS LAND BUT THEY GIVE
THE FIRST PRIORITY TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS.
THE REASON THAT WE ARE UPDATING
THIS IS WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD FLOOD
NUMBER JURISDICTIONS TRY TO
CIRCUMVENT THE STATE LAW AND WE
FEEL THAT.
THIS WELL FURTHER CLARIFY OUR
PURPOSE AND ACTUALLY STOP THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAD THAT OPENED THE
CITY COUNCIL ARGUED. THAT A
PARCEL AND WITHOUT SUBJECT TO
THE SURPLUS WHEN THAT BECAUSE
THE LAND WAS FORMERLY OWNED BY A
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
IN SAN JOSE. OF THE CITY TOOK A
STEP THAT THE CHARTER CITY THAT
THEY COULD ADOPTED ORDINANCE
THAT DIRECTLY CONTRADICTED THE
REQUIREMENTS.
OF THE SURPLUS LAND ACT AS YOU
KNOW WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A
HOUSING CRISIS AND IN PARTICULAR
WERE IN THE MIDST OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS.
WE FELT BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THE
LEGISLATION THAT THIS WAS ON.
THE WAY TO CREATE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN A COST
EFFICIENT WAY AND WE STILL STAND
BY THAT AND WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ARE FOR AB
TWENTY SIXTY FIVE WITH THAT I'VE
TWO WITNESSES.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ON MY NAME IS JEFFREY LOOK AND I
AM THE POLICY DIRECTOR WITH EAST
BAY HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS. WE
ARE A MEMBER BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT DOES EDUCATION
AND ADVOCACY TO PROTECT PRESERVE
AND.
S. BEYOND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND
TODAY.
PRIOR TO WORKING FOR EPO I SPENT
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS WITH THE
CITY OF OAKLAND IS THE HOUSING
POLICY AND PROGRAMS MANAGER SO I
HAVE. HAD SOME EXPERIENCE ON
THIS ISSUE ON BOTH SIDES.
I'M WE FIRST WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING FOR
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION.
THE SURPLUS LAND ACT CAN BE A
POWERFUL TOOL FOR PROVIDING
URGENTLY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. AND WE APPRECIATE
EFFORTS TO CLARIFYING AND
STRENGTHEN THE EXISTING
PROVISIONS IN THE LAW.
AS WE'VE NOTED IN THE COMMENT
LETTER THAT WE PREVIOUSLY
SUBMITTED IN THE COURSE OF OUR
WORK WE HAVE IDENTIFIED A NUMBER
OF BARRIERS TO EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LAW.
DESPITE EXPLICIT LANGUAGE IN
THE STATUTE THAT ITS PROVISIONS
APPLY EQUALLY TO GENERAL LAW AND
CHARTER CITIES AS MR TING SAID.
THERE'S A BIG DISPUTE AND
LITIGATION PENDING WITH THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE THAT HAS HAVE
BROADER RAMIFICATIONS THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. ON HAS BEEN TRYING
TO LINK DISCRETIONARY
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING TO.
POSITIVE PERFORMANCE ON A
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND SOUGHT TO
LINK DISCRETIONARY FUNDING TO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT BUT BECAUSE OF THIS.
DISPUTE WITH THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE RIGHT NOW THAT LINKAGE ONLY
APPLIES TO GENERAL LAWS CITIES.
AND THEY'VE HELD IT IN ARM
ABEYANCE FOR A CHARTER CITIES.
THREE YEARS AGO IN THE CITY OF
OAKLAND THE CITY CLAIMS THAT
LAND BEING OFFERED FOR SALE TO A
PRIVATE DEVELOPER OF MARKET RATE
HOUSING WAS NOT SUBJECT TO THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT BECAUSE IT WAS
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
LAND.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
DETERMINED THAT THE TRANSFER OF
THE PROPERTY FROM THE CITY TO
READ TO THE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
WAS INVALID AND D. O. F. WAS
ACTUALLY ORDERING THAT IT BE
CLAWED BACK. AND THEREFORE WAS
CLEARLY CITY OWNED PLANT.
MORE RECENTLY THE CITY OF
OAKLAND CLAIMS THAT A CITY OWNED
PARCEL BEING OFFERED TO A
PRIVATE DEVELOPER WAS NOT
SURPLUS LAND BECAUSE THE CURRENT
STATUTORY LANGUAGE REFERS TO
LAND THAT IS QUOTE. DETERMINES%
TO BE NO LONGER NECESSARY FOR
THE AGENCIES USE.
THE CITY CLAIMED THAT SINCE IT
HAD NEVER USED TO PLANT IT
DIDN'T FIT THE TEST OF NO LONGER
NECESSARY FOR THE CITY'S USE AND
THEREFORE THERE WAS NO
OBLIGATION TO GO THROUGH THE ON.
PROCEDURES OF THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT.
TRANSIT AGENCIES SEEKING
DISPOSABLE LAND FOR DEVELOPMENT
OF CLAIMED THAT BECAUSE FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY IN STATE
LAW DEFINED JOINT DEVELOPMENT AS
A TRANSIT RELATED USE SUCH
DISPOSITION STILL QUALIFIES AS
BEING USED BY THE AGENCY AND
THEREFORE. DEVELOPMENT OF OFFICE
AND RETAIL SPACE FOR EXAMPLE IS
PERMITTED WITHOUT NEEDING TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCEDURES OF THE
PLUS LAND ACT.
WE HAVE SEEN EFFORTS TO DEFINE
SALE OF WAY ON FOR ANY BROADLY
DEFINED PUBLIC PURPOSE SUCH AS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR REVENUE
GENERATION AS NOT BEING SURPLUS
LAND.
THERE'S BEEN CONFUSION ABOUT
WHAT IT MEANS TO GIVE PRIORITY
TO PROPOSALS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO ASSIST MEAN THAT IN
AGENCIES SHOULD FIRST NEGOTIATE
EXCLUSIVELY WITH DEVELOPERS
PROPOSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING. OR
JUST AT THE CITY IN THE COURSE
OF A COMPETITION SHOULD AWARD A
COUPLE OF EXTRA POINTS TO
ANYBODY PROPOSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND LASTLY WE'VE SEEN ATTEMPTS
TO USE THE NEGOTIATION PROCESS
ITSELF TO DIRECT OR LIMIT THE.
FINAL USE OF THE LAND.
INCLUDING SAYING WELL WE ONLY
WANT A HOTEL HERE WE ONLY WANT
TO SEE.
RETAIL DEVELOPMENT HERE DESPITE
THE STATUTE CLEARLY STATING THAT
NEGOTIATION SHOULD FOCUS ON
SALES PRICE OR LEASE TERMS AND
THAT IT IS FAILURE TO REACH
AGREEMENT ON THESE POINTS THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE AGENCY TO THEN
PROCEED. WITH SALE TO OTHER
ENTITIES.
THE AMENDMENTS OFFERED IN THIS
BILL WOULD GO A LONG WAY TOWARD
CLARIFYING IN RESOLVING THESE
AMBIGUITIES AND LOOPHOLES AND
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD.
PROVIDE CLARITY ABOUT WHICH
AGENCIES ARE COVERED BY THE LAW.
BETTER DEFINE SURPLUS LAND AS
ANY PUBLICLY OWNED PLANTS NOT
NEEDED FOR THE PUBLIC AGENCIES
OWN GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS AND
ESTABLISH A PRESUMPTION THAT
PUBLIC LAND IS SURPLUS PROPERTY
WHEN THE PUBLIC ENTITY INITIATES
ACTION TO DISPOSE OF IT.
BILL WOULD STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS FOR NOTIFYING QUALIFIED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
HAVE THE AVAILABILITY OF PUBLIC
LAND MAKING THAT PROCESS EASIER
FOR BOTH DEVELOPERS AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES RIGHT NOW. ARE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SPONSORS MUST
NOTIFY IN ADVANCE EVERY PUBLIC
AGENCY IN THEIR SERVICE AREA OF
THEIR DESIRE TO I'M HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BID ON. SURPLUS
LAND BEFORE THEY EVEN KNOW THAT
THE LAND IS BEING OFFERED THIS
IS INCREDIBLY BURDEN SUMMIT ALSO
REQUIRES SCORES OF AGENCIES TO
TRACK THIS. ON THE BILL PROPOSES
INSTEAD TO HAVE A CENTRAL
REGISTRY WITH EACH ARM COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS. THERE'S A
CENTRAL REPOSITORY.
THE BILL WOULD SPECIFY THAT
NEGOTIATION SHOULD FOCUS ON SALE
OR HOME LEASE PRICE IN TERMS AND
NOT THE DETAILS OF HOW THE
PROPERTY SHOULD BE DEVELOPED. IT
WOULD I CLARIFY WHAT IT MEANS TO
GRANT PRIORITY TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROPOSALS. I'M AND WOULD
CLARIFY FOR THAT IF NEGOTIATIONS
FAIL ON THERE'S A PROVISION NOW
THAT ANY HOUSING DEVELOP SHOULD
BE FIFTEEN PERCENT AFFORDABLE
THE ARM.
BILL NOW WOULD CLARIFY THAT IF
NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROPOSALS
THAT COME FORWARD BUT THE
PROPERTY IS SUBSEQUENTLY
DEVELOPED FOR HOUSING THAN THAT
FIFTEEN PERCENT WOULD REPLY.
SO THESE PROVISIONS IMPROVE ON
THE EXISTING STATUTE WITHOUT
IMPOSING SIGNIFICANT NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
REQUIREMENTS ON PUBLIC AGENCIES
AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE IS
FACING IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EMERGENCY ON AN UNPRECEDENTED
SCALE. ENSURING THAT SURPLUS
PUBLIC LAND IS MADE AVAILABLE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS OF THE UTMOST ARE
IMPORTANCE WE URGE YOU TO PASS
THIS MEASURE OUT OF COMMITTEE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
CURRY MEMBERS MICHAEL AND WITH
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA. A
PLEASED TO BE WITH YOU THAT
TODAY AND I WOULD JUST SAY VERY
BRIEFLY THAT THE STE SURPLUS
LAND ACTED ON THE BOOKS FOR
DECADES. IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
WORK MISTER TANK TO TO
STRENGTHEN THAT AND REALLY TRY
TO IMPLEMENT IT OVER THE PAST
THREE YEARS WE'VE LEARNED A LOT
OF A ABOUT TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
THE BILL AND FOUND ISSUES. THIS
SECTOR TO CLARIFY THE STATUTE
BECAUSE THE ONLY REMEDY THAT WE
HAVE REALLY IT'S A COMPLAINT
DRIVEN PROCESS AND WOULD REQUIRE
LITIGATION WE DON'T WANT TO GO
THERE WE THINK IT'S BETTER JUST
TO HAVE. MORE CLARITY IN THE LAW
SO THAT IT'S A JURISDICTIONS AND
DISTRICT KNOW HOW HOW IT
OPERATES AND TO BE ABLE TO DO SO
AND WE ARE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE THIS TO SUPPORT IF
YOU JUST GIVE YOUR NAME AND IF
YOU AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
THREE MEN TURKEY'S DONE HERE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE FOR SUPPORT.
NEW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BOB FROM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M BROWN JR VASI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. AND WE ARE REGRET
REGRETTABLY OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED TO THE MEASURE.
OUR OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS THE
APPLICATION OF THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT TO LEASES.
I'D THIS COULD BE VERY
PROBLEMATIC FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES
THAT DO HAVE VALID REASONS TO
LEASE OR OTHERWISE PROTECT THE
LAND THEY OWN.
FIRST FOR INSTANCE WE'VE HEARD
FROM OUR MEMBERS I'D.
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS ARE ARE
TYPICALLY USED TO PROTECT
SENSITIVE SPECIES OR TO MITIGATE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THAT THEY
FACE ANOTHER. AYE POTENTIAL I
USE OF LEASES WOULD BE SHORT
TERM WE SEEN OUGHT TO USE
PROPERTY PENDING FUTURE
FACILITIES NEEDS.
AS WE PASSED THE AUTHORED
CONSUMING TOO I CONSIDER
AMENDING THE DEFINITION TO APPLY
ONLY TO THE SALE OF SURPLUS
LAND.
WE ALSO ASKED FOR AMENDMENTS
THAT PUBLIC IN SEIZE.
ONLY BE REQUIRED TO OFFER LAND
THAT IS CONSIDERED SUITABLE FOR
SCHOOL FACILITIES OR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
UP WE'VE HEARD FROM ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO OFFER UP BUT FOR
LAND LOCATED NEXT TO WASTEWATER
FACILITIES. AND WE SERIOUSLY
DOUBT THAT ANYBODY WOULD WANT TO
CONSTRUCT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINALLY THE CAN ALSO BE GOOD
REASONS FOR AN AGENCY TO IT.
TO HAVE INFORMAL NEGOTIATION AND
IF THE AGENCY COMPLIES THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT. BY PROVIDING
NOTICE AND NEGOTIATION IN GOOD
FAITH THAT SHOULD BE ALL THAT IS
REQUIRED.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR FOR WORKING WITH US
IN THE BILL SO FAR. AND WE
BELIEVE THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
HAVE PROPOSED TO INCREASE THE
LAND AVAILABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ALSO MAINTAINING
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL AGENCIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHERS
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION. HIGH
ON MY GROUPS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALVARY MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND WE TACKLE THE
CONCERNS OF THE SPECIAL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION AND APPRECIATE THE
THE AUTHORED STAFF AND SPONSORS
FOR. MEETING WITH US AND TALKING
WITH US AND HOPEFULLY.
HOME KEEP WORKING ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
POST.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HER
STEERED HIM AFTER THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA WE
AGAIN CONCUR WITH THE REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS I'M OUTLINED BY THE
SPECIAL TO.
ASSOCIATION AND ARE OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JUST GO GAGA
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES ALSO OPPOSE
MUST AMENDED WOULD JUST OUTLINED
THEIR COMMENTS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUE HERE FROM C. FTA
THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY WILL OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SO JUST FOR CLARITY SAKE A I
BELIEVE THAT.
THE.
AUTHOR
BEGAN BY STATING HE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS.
SO IN OPPOSITION THEY WERE SAY
AND.
.
THE WAS SPEAKING OF WHAT
APPEARED TO BE ADDITIONAL
MINUTES BUT BEYOND THAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS OR WE TALK ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HE ACCEPTED.
WOULD SATISFY THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE OPPOSITION IS SPEAKING
OF. MISTREATING WENCH LIKE TO
ANSWER THAT I I BELIEVE THAT THE
AMENDMENTS WE ACCEPTED DON'T
ADDRESS THEIR ISSUE.
WERE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO.
DISCUSSED THE ISSUE IN REGARDS
TO TWO PARTICULAR THAT WE'VE
UNDERSTOOD HIS SHORT TERM LEASES
UNDER TO YOU TEN YEARS. AN
EASEMENT THEM BUFFER ZONES USED
BY WATER TREATMENT PLANTS AND
OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO.
WORK WITH THE AGENCIES I THINK
WE CAN REACH AGREEMENT.
AND THE LEASING ISSUE.
I THE DEATH OF THESE ISSUES
FIRST I MENTIONED WAS SHORT IS
UNDER TEN YEARS I THINK WE CAN
ADDRESS THAT AS WELL
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE.
WAS THERE WOULD DO WE ALREADY
HAVE A MOTION DIXIE.
OKAY WE NEED.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMAN FOR.
GLORIA AND A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
NOW THAT THIS HAS A TAPE OF
AMENDMENTS.
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU AND WE
AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM I APPRECIATE THEM
YOU'RE OFFERING TO DO THAT. AND.
WILL HAVE A CLOSING STATEMENT
PICKS
A I AGAIN WE YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS I THINK THIS IS A
PRUDENT WAY TO APPROACH IT. WE
HAPPILY WILL BE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OUR SPECIAL DISTRICTS I
BELIEVE WE CAN FIND
ACCOMMODATION FOR THEM AND.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FIVE.
I GREW THREAT THAT THE SURPLUS
PLANTS LAND SURPLUS PLANTS WITH
MOUTHFUL. ACT MEANS MORE TEETH
ON PLEASE A SUPPORT TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION.
EXIT.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WE ARE CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I LACKEY. LACKEY
NOVOTEL.
VOEPEL NO.
IT.
A THAT'S OUT FIVE TO THREE THINK
AGREEMENT MUCH.
I'M NOT SEE MISTER CORE CARILLO
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT.
WELCOME.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO BEGIN.
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU A
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'VE ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
TO ONLY ALLOW AN INCREASE OF
FINES FOR BUILDING AND SAFETY
CODES NOT GENERAL ORDINANCE
VIOLATIONS.
I BELIEVE THAT'S THE ONLY
AMENDMENT YOU'VE ASKED ME TO
TAKE.
ALRIGHT THEN AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT INCREASES THE FINES
CITIES AND COUNTIES CAN LEVEL
LEVY.
AGAINST BUILDING PROPERTY OWNERS
FOR VIOLATIONS OF LOCAL BUILDING
AND SAFETY CODE VIOLATIONS.
THIS BILL ADDITIONALLY REQUIRE
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO DEVELOP A
HARDSHIP WAIVER.
CITY'S ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
STRUGGLE
WITH HOW TO DEAL WITH BLIGHTED
AND ABANDONED BUILDINGS
WHEN PROPERTY COUNTIES REFUSED
TO MAINTAIN THEIR PROPERTY.
OVER LONG PERIODS OF TIME. IT
LEADS TO AN ACCUMULATION OF
DEBRIS AND PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERN
CHURCHES BREAK INS CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY AND EVEN FIRES.
AND SOME OF THESE CAN BE VERY
DESTRUCTIVE.
IN MY DISTRICT
RIGHT ACROSS A PATIO.
FROM MY DISTRICT OFFICE IN
HAYWARD.
THERE IS AN ABANDONED COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY WHICH HAS BEEN
ABANDONED FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS.
I IT'S ELEVEN STORY BUILDING
AND.
WE.
WE HAD FIRES WE'VE HAD OTHER
PROBLEMS.
PROPERTIES LIKE THIS ONE IN MY
DISTRICT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
BE RESTORED. INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SHOPPING AREAS OFFICE
BUILDINGS
MIXED USE IT CETERA.
WITH ME TODAY.
FIRST I'M GONNA I'D LIKE TO
HAVE THE MAYOR OF HAYWARD.
MY FORMER.
COLLEAGUES ON THE CITY COUNCIL
BARBARA HALLIDAY SPEAK.
AND THEN NOW DAN CARRICK AT TO
DISCUSS THIS HE'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CITIES.
TWO OF THE MAYOR I THINK YOU YES
I'M I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I WANNA. THANK BUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SHEET FOR.
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
I AM SURE I SPEAK WELL I KNOW I
SPEAK FOR OUR STAFF AND I'M
PRETTY SURE I SPEAK FOR MY
COLLEAGUES ALTHOUGH I HAVEN'T
PULLED THEM THAT WOULD BE
AGAINST THE BROWN ACT BUT. I BUT
I KNOW THAT THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN HAYWARD
AND.
AND HAS BEEN FOR QUITE SOMETIME
THIS.
BUILDING THAT A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK REFERRED TO IS CONTINUES
TO BE A PROBLEM AND WE DO NEED.
TURNED OUT STRONGER TOOLS TO
DEAL WITH THIS AND AND THIS WILL
WILL GIVE US SOME OF THOSE ARE
STAFF ESTIMATES THAT WE DID IT
THAT ABANDONED PROBABILITIES AND
PRIVATE PROPERTY AND HEY WERE
GENERATE OVER TWO HUNDRED.
COMPLAINTS A YEAR AND OFTEN
THESE INVOLVE CALLS FOR SERVICE
FROM OUR PUBLIC SERVICE ARE YOU
KNOW.
PUBLIC PUBLIC SERVICE AGENCIES
OUR POLICE AND FIRE A WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO RECOVER THESE COSTS.
AND IT SEEMS OF MINDS ARE SO LOW
THAT THE PROPERTY OWNERS IT JUST
DOESN'T GET THEIR ATTENTION.
AND.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK.
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT THIS LAND IS
SO NEEDED AND THERE HAVE BEEN
PROPOSALS FOR THIS ELEVEN STORY
BUILDING TO BE TURNED INTO A
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING MULTI FAMILY
RENTAL HOUSING THAT WE REALLY
NEED.
THE OWNER JUST DOESN'T WANT TO
SELL IT DE SATISFIED WITH THE
STATUS QUO WE NEED TO GET HIS
ATTENTION WILL AND AND THIS IS
TRUE OF MANY PROPERTIES IN OUR
CITY SO.
BY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE TODAY AND SPEAK AND I WOULD
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MR CHARACTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON KNOW MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TO ACCURATE WITH WE GET
CALIFORNIA CITIES ON THIS BILL
IS ALSO WAS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO CONVEY THEIR SUPPORT
WALL. ON A THAT THIS BILL ARE
OBVIOUSLY THERE OR ALL OR OTHERS
IF OTHER TOOLS OUT THERE THIS IS
ONE TOOL.
THE THAT THE THE.
THE TH THE THREAT THRESHOLDS A
STATUTORY THRESHOLDS IN THE LAW
HAVE BEEN UPDATED FOR INFLATION
FOR AWHILE BUT WE THINK THAT'S
THAT'S HELPFUL AND THEN
SPECIFICALLY ARE WHEN WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IS
CONCERNS ABOUT. A TRIED TO MAKE
SURE THERE WAS SOMETHING FOR
THESE COMMERCIAL PROPERTY
OWNERS.
IN THIS THIS BILL BASICALLY
TRACKS THE. VIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW MOANS BILL FROM LAST YEAR IN
TERMS OF HEAVEN ATTENTION
GETTING TYPE OF LEVEL WHAT WE
ULTIMATELY WANT AS COMMUNITIES
IS WE JUST WANT THE PROPERTIES
MAINTAINED. AND SO TO THE EXTENT
THIS HELPS WE THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANYONE ELSE
UP IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
ALRIGHT REVENUE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME.
MY ANGER I'M LEGISLATIVE
ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE REGISTERED OUR
OPPOSITION BECAUSE.
OF IMPACTS RAISING THE FINES FOR
ALL MUNICIPAL INFRACTIONS AND
COUNTY INFECTIONS BUT HAVE WE
APPRECIATE. THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO AMEND THAT DOWN
TO THIS SPECIFIC AREAS THEY'RE
LOOKING AT AND ONCE THOSE
AMENDMENTS GOING TO PRINT AND WE
CAN REVIEW WILL MOVE OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MICRO WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE HAD A SIMILAR
POSITION TO THE ACLU WE'RE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS. TAKEN OUR COMMENTS TO A TO
HEART AND.
HAS AGREED TO AMEND THOSE
SECTIONS OUT AND WE ALSO LOOK
FOR HOPEFULLY IN THE FUTURE
WORKING ON THE HARDSHIP
EXEMPTION WE DID. PROVIDE THE
AUTHOR SOME LANGUAGE ON THAT AND
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD ABOUT
HOW WE CAN STRENGTHEN THAT
PROVISION BUT AS FOR NOW OUR
OPPOSITION AND LET'S AMENDED HIS
BEEN REMOVED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SOME ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY OTHER THREE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
YEAH OKAY CSUS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL.
THE AUTHOR.
.
IS.
DOING A PRETTY GOOD BILL HERE.
NINE SO I WILL STILL OPPOSE IT A
TELL YOU WHY GONNA MAKE SENSE
OKAY. YOU KNOW HE'S HE'S MY GOOD
FRIEND I DO ITS JOB WE'RE GOOD
FRIENDS YEAH.
AND IT'S BASED ON YOUR LOGIC.
WE HAVE NOT RAISED THESE
VIOLATIONS.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
SAFETY AND CODE VIOLATIONS WE
HAVE NOT RAISED HIM FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE.
AS A CONSERVATIVE
IT'S GREAT WITH ME.
ALRIGHT.
THAT'S FINE.
SORRY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE ALWAYS
ENCOUNTERED BECAUSE OURS.
CITY WERE I WAS ON THE COUNCIL
OF SOME OLDER CITY WITH THE
URBAN CORE. THAT NEEDED TO BE.
REVITALIZED.
.
A LOT OF THE PROPERTIES THAT WE
SAW WERE NOT OWNER OCCUPIED THEY
WERE IN A SPECIAL IN THE
COMMERCIAL AREAS. THEY WERE
BASICALLY WRITE OFFS FOR A
LANDLORD THAT LIVED YOU KNOW.
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY IN SOME
INSTANCES SO. THAT WAS NO
INCENTIVE TO FIX THEM UP BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T EVEN LIVE THERE THAN
IN DRIVE BY THEM THEY THEN HAVE
TO LOOK AT THEM THEY THEN HAVE
TO DEAL WITH. THE CRIME AND THE
GRAFFITI AND ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WENT ON WITH IT. SO.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY. AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE'LL SEE HOW IT
GOES FROM THERE. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
A SYRIAN ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
I'M SCHOOL WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON WE
HAVE THE SAME PROBLEMS AND MY
MAYOR HERE WILL LIVE TESTIFY BY
AND NOT AT THE HEAD THAT WE'VE
SEEN THE SAME THING.
THANK YOU I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLY GLORIA AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
SO I'VE FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOU FIRST OF ALL I REALLY LIKED
FACTORS ARE COLLABORATING
WORKING ON TRYING TO FIND FIND A
SOLUTION. THAT MAKES IT REALLY
REALLY PLEASE SO THANK YOU I
KNOW YOU THIS BILL CAME OUT LAST
YEAR YOU THERE'S SOME QUESTIONS
REYES IT SEEMS LIKE YOU GUYS ARE
ADDRESSING AND. SO WITH THAT I
WILL BE WITH THE AMENDMENTS THE
TECHNO AMENDMENTS I WILL BE
AVOIDING AYE THIS AFTERNOON.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR CURRY. ANGLER CURRY AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE BLOOM. BLOOM
I'VE COVER GYRO.
COOLEY COOLEY AYE GLORIA. GLORY
I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO.
BECAUSE AT SEVEN ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SAVE EVERYONE.
YEAH WHY DON'T YOU GO AHEAD AND
HAVE.
THE NEXT ONE WHICH WOULD
MEMBERS THAT WENT HOME BUT.
IT'S TWENTY FOUR NINETY ONE
CITY INCORPORATION FINANCING
RIGHT SISTER ALREADY HAVING HIM
MRS KRISTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK AND HOPE YOU DON'T MIND
MISS A GREAT US FOR JUST GONNA
GET THIS ONE DONE WHILE HE'S
HERE. OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT NOW NUMBER A ELEVEN AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY ONE THIS IS
WITH. ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
QUIRK
WELCOME GENTLEMAN.
I MEAN.
WITH MY NEW FRIEND.
MY NEW FRIEND TO MISS MCDONNELL
EXCELLENT.
ANALYSIS. IN THE TIMING ROLLOUT
RAFFIN THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS.
IT'S.
.
LITTLE BIT LIKE THE OLD
SYSTEMATIC THEOLOGIANS ACTUALLY
OKAY YOU GONNA GET INTO TO
MINNESOTA TALK.
GO DOWN DEEPER STAYED ON LONGER
COME UP DRYER THAT WAS YOUR
ANALYSIS VERY WELL DONE.
.
COLLEAGUES A. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
ONE TODAY.
IT FOCUS ON SUPPORTING LOCAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
IMPROVE THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE
AND FORMER CITY.
TO SORT OF MY PERSONAL. ODYSSEY.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED S. B. EIGHTY NINE TO HELP
CLOSE A HUGE BUDGET GAP.
THAT BILL REMOVED ALLOCATIONS OF
THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE VLF FROM
CITIES.
PRACTICALLY MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR NEW CITIES THAT REVENUE
STREAM FROM THE VEAL IT BECAME
VERY KEY IS SAID INNER CITIES IN
MOTION.
SO WE HAVE NOT HAD A CORPORATION
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINE ONE
RESTORES IS CRITICAL FINANCING
MECHANISM.
OF THAT LOCAL CREWS TO UTILIZE
TO INCORPORATE. AND MIGHT JOINT
AUTHORS DOCTOR QUIRK AND WE ALSO
HAVE DAN CAREFULLY TO CITIES AND
MICHAEL SEMEN FROM ARDEN ARCADE.
AND HEARING THE EIGHTH DECEMBER
DISTRICT VERY FOCUSED ON NEAR
FUTURE AND HOW TO IMPROVE IT
SOLD DOT QUIRK.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES.
I'M HAPPY TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORED THIS BILL WHICH HAS A
DIRECT IMPACT IN MY DISTRICT.
I REPRESENT MOST OF THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS SHOULD
ALAMEDA COUNTY. OUR NUMBER OF
THEM DO WOULD LIKE TO BECOME
CITIES IN PARTICULAR CASTRO
VALLEY IS VERY ACTIVE AND VOCAL.
ABOUT THE NEED TO BE
INCORPORATED CITY AND DETERMINE
THEIR OWN DESTINY.
THEY HAVE MET WITH MY STAFF BOTH
IN THE CAPITAL IN DISTRICT
ADVOCATE FOR THE NEED FOR
INCORPORATION.
THIS BILL HELPS COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE TAKE A STEP TOWARDS MAKING
THAT A REALITY.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GREAT.
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE A AMEND
CHAIRMAN WRIST ACCURATE WITH
LEAGUE CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE
LAST YEAR WITH SP ONE THIRTY THE
LEGISLATURE FIXED A ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS ARE RELATEDTO THIS UP
PASSED LAW. FOR THE FOR A RECENT
INCORPORATED CITIES JOHN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THIS BILL
BASICALLY GIVES FUTURE
CORPORATIONS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY OUGHT TO MOVE
FORWARD.
MICHAEL SYMON ARE KNOW ARCADE
RESIDENT SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT MEMBER OF OUR ADVOCATES
FOR ART MEDICAID AND A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
UNINCORPORATED NOW WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL REQUEST YOUR
AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY ANYONE ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE.
A SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LIKE WE HAVE A COUPLE MANY.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE GORGEOUS
AND I'M PRESIDENT OF THE SELECT
A CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. IS THE
LARGEST UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY
IN STANISLAUS COUNTY CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE BEEN UNDER ANNEXATION
THREAT BY THE CITY MODESTO FOR
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS. MUCH. OF
ESPECIALLY IN PARTIAL
ANNEXATIONS.
OF MODESTO HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
SUED FOR TRYING TWO. OF THEM
ANNEX OTHER AREAS AND.
NOT ANNEXING IN DISADVANTAGED
OF MINORITY COMMUNITIES WITHIN
ITS BOUNDARIES SO INCORPORATION
IS THE ONLY AVENUE THAT WE HAVE
TO PROTECT OUR BOUNDARIES. AND
NOT LOSE ANY MORE PARTIAL
ANNEXATIONS FROM OUR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
WELL WE HAVE ALREADY LOST COSTS
GOING KAISER IN THE RESIDENTS
WANT TO PACK AND I HAVE TO TALK
ALL THE TIME OR NOT GET IT BACK
SO. A SLIGHT WOULD BE
OVERWHELMINGLY IN FAVOR FROM
CORPORATION SO THANK YOU FOR. A
CONSIDERING THE SPELL THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CARL DOKKUM MEMBER OF THE
ADVOCATES FOR ART ARCADE INTO
RESIDENTS SOCK NO COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIRTY ONE
IN THE IN HERE IN OPPOSING THIS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ARE THE QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY.
PROMOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND I BELIEVE THOSE FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO FILL.
ALL JUST TO ADD AT THIS PROBLEM
ARE WHAT HAPPENS IS.
A NEARBY CITY WILL WANT TO GO TO
ALLEN CORPORATE AREA
UNINCORPORATED AREA THEY WON'T
WANT ANYTHING TO DO WITH
HOUSING.
BUT THEY'LL TRY AND TAKE.
THE COMMERCIAL AREAS THE MAIN
DRAG.
AND AS THE ADVOCATE HERE SAID
WHEN YOU DO THAT YOU MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THAT CITY. TO
EVER HAVE IN ECONOMIC BASE SAID
THE SOONER WE CAN DO THIS THE
BETTER.
THANK YOUR ANYTHING RESEARCH
CLOTHING LARGEST CONCLUDED MY
OWN NARRATIVE RANCHO CORDOVA.
WHEN MY KIDS WERE GROWING UP
GOING TO HIGH SCHOOL THEY
REFERRED TO MY CITY AS RANCHO
CORDOVA.
AS I WENT DOOR TO DOOR TALKING
TO PEOPLE ABOUT CITYHOOD. I
WOULD HAVE PEOPLE COME OUT AND
REFER TO THE FACT THAT THE FILM.
ACTUALLY HAD BECOME THE DUMPING
GROUND OF THE COUNTY.
I I REMEMBER ONE GUY WHO IS IN A
FRESHLY PRESSED LINEN SHIRT
CHRIS KHAKI SLACKS ALSO. FOR A
FEW PLAYERS DIE CONTRA LONG
WHICH IS VERY RARE RANCHO
CORDOVA SO JUST VERY ELEGANT
COME UNTIL IT WOULD BECOME THE.
ARMPIT OF THE COUNTY
THAT TOO WAS SORT OF A SHOCKING
SORT OF CHARACTERIZATION.
WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO IS IT
WILL LET COMMUNITIES?
WHERE YOU HAVE AN ENERGY TO
IMPROVE THEIR FUTURE?
TO GET TOGETHER AND WORK ON THAT
PROBLEM. THOSE SORTS
SECURITIZATION ARRANGEMENT OVER
NEVER HAPPEN ANYMORE.
AND I DO THINK IT IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PURPOSE A GOVERNMENT
KIND RELEASED THE ENERGY OF OUR
CITIZENS IN DESTRUCTIVE WAYS.
AND.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THE WITHIN
THE FUNDING HERE THERE'S THERE'S
VLF MONEY BUT THERE'S ALSO A
FORM OF IT THAT REFLECTS KIND OF
GROWTH IN RICHARD VOTING. RICH
YOUR VOTE ROLE.
AND IN MY CITY I WENT DOOR TO
DOOR.
AFTER THE VOTERS HAD PASSED
CITYHOOD
BUT BEFORE THE START UPDATE TO
REGISTER VOTERS.
BECAUSE EVERY NEW REGISTERED
VOTER IN MY CITY WHO ENTERED THE
ROLES BECAUSE I KNOCKED ON THEIR
DOOR WAS HELPING THE FUTURE THE
CITY BY INCREASING THIS LITTLE
BIT OF FUNDING STREAM.
SO ON SO MANY LEVELS THIS
ACTIVITY ENERGIZES DEMOCRACY
GROWS A GREAT FUTURE LETS PEOPLE
FOCUS ON THEIR AREA SO I'M JUST
PLEASED TO BE HERE I URGE YOU
RIGHT VOTE I THINK FOR YOUR
TIME.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING A BILL
TODAY.
YOU KNOW FOR THE ABILITY FOR
COMMUNITIES TO INCORPORATE SOME
OF REALLY IMPORTANT SO THEY CAN
MOVE FORWARD TO DO ALL THE
THINGS THAT. ALL OF YOU
TESTIFIED I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR.
COMMENTS TODAY FROM SALINAS SO
BUT THAT.
DIXIE WE. THROW PLEASE
PROMOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR CURRY AYE
AYE AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
BILLS THAT EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GENTLEMEN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AREAS.
WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS LOCATED ON THE
LAST PAGE OF THE ANALYSIS.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY EIGHT IS A
MEASURE BUILT ON FAIRNESS.
THAT WOULD
STORE REVENUES PREVIOUSLY
ADVOCATE ALLOCATED TO CITIES
THAT ANNEXED UNINHABITED I'M
SORRY. INHABITED TERRITORIES.
HAD PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF SB
EIGHTY NINE.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SP EIGHTY
NINE A PREVIOUS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. WAS PASSED DURING STATE
BUDGET DIFFICULTIES.
THIS LEGISLATION IN EFFECT SWEPT
AWAY TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. IN VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
REVENUES FROM CITIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
AS A PART OF THIS CHANGE MANY OF
THOSE AFFECTED WERE NEWLY
INCORPORATED AREAS AND CITIES
THAT HAD AMEX THOSE NEW
TERRITORIES.
THIS BECAUSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ULTIMATELY LOSE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN REVENUE.
THERE OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
ANNEXING CITIES WHO LOST REVENUE
DUE TO THE LEGISLATION.
INCLUDING MY CITY THE CITY OF
FONTANA.
FONTANA IN MY DISTRICT WHICH
LOSES OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
FOR ANNEXING CITIES MANY OF
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY CASH
STRAPPED.
THE LOS OF THIS CRITICAL SOURCE
OF FUNDING HURTS THE RESIDENTS.
CITY'S PUT IN THIS POSITION
OFTEN MOST CUT CRITICAL SERVICES
SUCH IS INVESTING IN LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PUBLIC SAFETY
IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE FOR WHAT
MANY CONSIDER TO BE AN
INCOMPLETE BUDGET.
ANOTHER PRACTICAL EFFECT OF
LOCAL LAW.
CURRENT LAW IS THE REDUCTION OF
INTEREST IN ANNEXATION.
GIVEN THE LIMITATIONSREGARDING
NEW REVENUE THEY ARE. THEY'RE NO
LONGER ABLE TO OBTAIN AS A
RESULT OF SB EIGHTY NINE CITIES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO SEE
ANNEXATION AS BURDENSOME.
WELL WE DON'T GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TOOLS NECESSARY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
RESIDENTS WE ARE ACTIVELY
CREATING A DISINCENTIVE FOR
ANNEXATION.
WE MUST EMPOWER OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS ACQUITTED A
WORN MAYOR OF SAN BERNADINE
KNOW.
AS WELL AS DAN CARRICK.
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES WHO ARE THE SPONSORS OF
THIS LEGISLATION.
PULLING MEDICARE HIM WITHIN
THAT'S RIGHT.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH HONORABLE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING MY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS RESIDENTS
OF THE CITY OF FONTANA.
BUT WE ARE A REGIONAL CITY THAT
ENCOMPASSES FAMILY DINO ALSO AND
ALL THE OTHER CITIES IMPACTED BY
THIS ISSUE.
ALONG TWO THOUSAND SIX GAVE THE
CITY'S OR CITIES WITH NEW
ANNEXATIONS ADDITIONAL VEHICLE
LICENSE BE REVENUE TO HELP PAPER
SERVICES IN THESE AREAS.
THE CITY OF FONTANA ANNEX
THIRTEEN SQUARE MILES WITH THE
PROMISE OF FUNDING TO TAKE CARE
OF OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN THAT AREA. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN S. B. EIGHTY
NINE UNINTENTIONALLY REMOVE THE
FUNDS FROM THESE NEW AREAS
THIS WILL. HAVE THIS HAS
AFFECTED A HUNDRED AND FORTY
CITIES AND FONTANA TOOK A
SUBSTANTIAL LOSS.
S. B. EIGHTY NINE RESULTED IN A
PER CAPITA LOSS THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS CITIES OF THREE
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS PER
RESIDENT BY CONTRAS.
THE PER CAPITA LOS OF THE CITY
OF FONTANA WAS SEVEN DOLLARS AND
FIFTY CENTS PER RESIDENT.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY EIGHT WILL
REINSTATE BILLS LOST REVENUES
AND GREEN NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ANNUALLY BACK TO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
PART OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME ARE
APPOINTED POLICE CHIEF.
CHIEF BILLY GREEN AND OUR FIRE
CHIEF
JEFF BRIDGE FEEL TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION WE NEED MORE
OFFICERS IN FONTANA WE NEED MORE
PUBLIC SAFETY IN THESE AREAS.
THIS LEGISLATION IS FOR OUR
STATE FUTURE WITHOUT THIS
FUNDING
CITIES WILL NOT BE ABLE TO ANNEX
AREAS TO IMPROVE SERVICE LEVELS.
MADAM CHAIR FOR THESE REASONS WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND WE
RESPECTIVELY REQUEST
AND HE A BOWL IN THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M OF THE
ANY OTHERS THAT WANT TO SPEAK.
A MEASURE MEMBERS SO DAN CARRIED
WITH WE GET CALIFORNIA CITIES
ARE THE HUNDRED FORTY CITIES.
THAT WERE AFFECTED BY THIS ARE
THEY WERE THEY'D GONE OUT AND
DONE THE RIGHT THING.
IN WERE RELYING ON REVENUES.
IT WHEN THEY TOOK IN NEW
NEWPORT NEW COMMUNITIES TO
PORTLAND THIS REVENUES WERE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES.
OF THE BILL THAT WENT THROUGH
WENT THROUGH WITH NO HEARINGS IT
WAS WHERE AND.
AND WIPED OUT I IMMEDIATELY SO
THIS IS ABOUT FIXING THAT AND
BEING ABLE TO ALLOW THESE
COMMUNITIES A TO MOVE FORWARD
AND OBVIOUSLY THE CITY OF
FONTANA WAS WAS THE HARDEST HIT.
BY THIS BY THIS SONG BY THIS UP
PROPOSAL SO WE THINK THIS BILL
IS REALLY NECESSARY.
AND WAS VERY HELPFUL TO A
NUMBER OF OUR CITY SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
HI I'M SCUTTLING THE FINANCE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF CHICO
WE WERE ALSO HIT BY THIS IS
FONTANA WAS. WE WERE CLOSE TO
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS
SO WE FEEL YOUR PAIN.
IN MANY ASPECTS IN SO I'M JUST
HERE TO ECHO SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF OUR CITY AND
HOPE YOU WILL SAY I.
THANK YOU IS ANYONE ELSE THE
AUDIENCE.
SUPPORT THE BILL.
BILLY GREEN NOT THE INCOMING CAP
I'M SORRY THE INCOMING CHIEF OF
POLICE FOR THE CITY OF FONTANA.
I. THINK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
BE HERE TODAY AND I JUST WANTED
TO BRING TO LIGHT THE EMPHASIS
ACROSS OUR NATION. ARE GONE
SCHOOL SAFETY BUT THIS COINCIDES
WITH THE LOSS OF OUR SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER PROGRAM. OF THE
CITY OF FONTANA NO LONGER HAS A
SCHOOL POLICE OFFICER ARMS CITY
OF FONTANA POLICE OFFICERS IN
THE SCHOOLS.
WHICH WE DID.
BEFORE WE LOST THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WITH THE BURDENS WERE
PUTTING ON OUR YOUNG OFFICERS
TODAY OF DEALING WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS WITH THE OP LIKE
CRISIS. ARE THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND HAVING OFFICERS ON
THE STREET.
WOULD BE NOT ONLY BENEFICIAL A
TO THE RESIDENTS OF FONTANA BUT
THE THE KIDS AND STAFF MEMBERS
THAT GO TO SCHOOL IN OUR
COMMUNITY AS WELL.
JEFF PERCH FILL THE FIRE CHIEF
FONTANA THANK YOU AGAIN. OF ART
ANNEXED AREAS ARE UNINCORPORATED
AREAS OF FONTANA ARE HER OLDER
POPULATION OUR OF OUR STRUCTURES
ARE MUCH OLDER AS WELL.
THEREFORE THEY'RE NOT THAT
SPRINKLER. LIKE THE REST OF THE
INCORPORATED PART OF THE CITY IS
THERE FOR ITS AND PARAMOUNT FOR
US TO PROVIDE A QUICK.
EFFECTIVE FIRE SUPPRESSION.
IN THOSE AREAS SPECIFICALLY AS
WELL AS THE ADVANCED LIFE
SUPPORT WE RELY ON OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN THOSE AREAS TO
BACK US UP AND PROVIDE SECURITY
FOR US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHASING ANTS ALL THIS
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
FONTANA'S WAS THE CITY OF
THOUSAND OAKS AND STRONG SUPPORT
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
GOVERNMENT AMOUNT CHAIR RANKS
AMONG THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
WE'RE LOOKING AT A LITTLE OVER
HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WE'VE LOST FROM OUR
CONTRACT CITY SO WE ARE JUST
SUPPORT THANK YOU GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO ALEX GIVES HIM AFTER THE
CITY OF SAN RAMON IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOROTHY JOHNSON
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES WE DON'T HAVE
PHYSICIAN ON THE BILL AND THAT'S
A TESTAMENT TO THE GOOD WORK
DONE HERE TO OUR RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS WITH EARLIER VERSIONS
SO I THINK THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
THE SPONSORS AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE DEDICATION TAKE GET THE
SPELL TOOK PLACE WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE TO OPPOSE THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIRTY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I AND WE HAVE A
MOTION BROUGHT FROM A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM IN MY CORRECT AND
SECOND I WALDRON.
AUTHORS CLOSING. A GRAYSON. MY
HEARING I KNOW SIDE.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES IN SUPPORT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
OKAY WELL I AM I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD UP
FROM MANY REASONS BECAUSE I WANT
TO SEE COMMUNITIES GET WHOLE
AGAIN. AND SO I KNOW THIS TOOK
SOME TIME TO GET IT.
TO WHERE IT IS TODAY I.
YOU HAVE ACCEPTED THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AS WELL AND.
WITH THAT. PLEASE TAKE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WE ARE CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CABALLERO
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE VOEPEL.
BILLS US SEVEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU OKAY
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
CHIU WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE OR
LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW
ALLOWING FOR THE FORMATION OF AN
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT AN I FD. ALONG THE PORT
OF SAN FRANCISCO TO FUND
IMPROVEMENTS.
TO AGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HISTORIC RESOURCES
AS THE SAN FRANCISCO PORTS
MANAGES PUBLIC TRUST LANDS FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WOULD REVISE THE SAN
FRANCISCO I'VE DE LAW TO INCLUDE
SHORELINE PROTECTION FOR OUR SAN
FRANCISCO SEA WALL.
THE EMBARCADERO SEA WALL WHICH
PROTECTS THE SAN FRANCISCO
WATERFRONT WAS BUILT OVER A
CENTURY AGO. IT IS UNFORTUNATE
RAPIDLY BECAME HIGHLY VULNERABLE
TO EARTHQUAKE AND HOT HIGHLY
VULNERABLE TO SEA LEVEL RISE.
THE SEA WALL IS A CRITICAL
REGIONAL AND STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSETS.
PROTECTS OVER A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
IT'S WHERE TWENTY FOUR MILLION
VISITORS TO CALIFORNIA EACH
YEAR.
SPEND TIME WHERE MILLIONS LIVE
WORK AND PLAY THE SEA WALL ALSO
PROTECTS CRITICAL UTILITY
NETWORKS AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR OUR BACK.
THE AMENDMENTS TO THE I'VE D.
LAW WOULD AUTHORIZE FUNDS FOR
SHORELINE PROTECTION AND TO
REBUILD THE SEA WALL. AND IT'S
PART OF A BROADER PLAN FOR
FUNDING FROM LOCAL FEDERAL AND
PRIVATE SECTOR SOURCES AND I
APPRECIATE THE BROAD SUPPORT FOR
IT CHANGES FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
I'M REALLY PLEASED THAT HERE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IS OUR SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR MARK FARRELL AS
WELL AS BRAD BENSON WITH OUR
PORT OF SAN FRANCISCO TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
WELCOME MAYOR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE BE
APPARENT SACRAMENTO. I'M I WANT
TO THANK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR SPONSORING THIS BILL YOU
KNOW AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
MENTION OUR.
SEA WALL IN SAN FRANCISCO WAS
BUILT OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT
PROTECTS OVER A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS OF ASSETS INCLUDING
CRITICAL.
INFRASTRUCTURE CRITICAL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS FOR THE
REGION INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT PART
OF THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO NOT
TO MENTION MORE TOURISM.
ESTIMATES TO FIX THIS SEA WALL
IS RANGE BETWEEN TWO TO FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS BILL WILL
GO AWAY TOWARDS ON FIXING THAT
IN TOWARD TOWARD THE FINANCING
OF IT IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
MENTION THIS IS A COMBINATION OF
STATE AND LOCAL FEDERAL DOLLARS.
I WILL SAY THAT INSTANCES GO WE
ARE PUTTING A A THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR BOND ON THE
BALLOT THIS NOVEMBER
SPECIFICALLY TOWARD TO SEE WALL.
SO I'M HERE TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CONSIDERING THIS
AND AND FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW
WE ARE ALSO DO VIEW THIS IS A
TRUE PARTNERSHIP AND WILL DO A
TON AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL.
AND WITH US TODAY IS BRAD BENSON
FROM REPORT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS
WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON LIKE THIS SAY A
COUPLE OF WORDS.
BUT ADVANCING WITH THE PORT OF
SAN FRANCISCO KAREN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
YOU'RE WELCOME OUR FIRST FALL
REVENUE AND OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SHERRY AT PEMBERTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION THE LANDS COMMISSION
DOESN'T YET HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT IS
SLATED TO TAKE A POSITION AT ITS
MEETING NEXT WEEK. AND AS STAFF
WE FULLY SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
THE COMMISSION HAS WORKED FOR
MANY MANY YEARS WITH THE PORT
TOGETHER TOWARD A COMMON GOAL OF
PROTECTING THE WATERFRONT AND
FULLY SUPPORTS THE EFFORTS TO
ACQUIRE FUNDING TO. REPAIR THE
STEEL BALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. MANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AS HAVE A QUICK
COMMENT IF I COULD.
I AM VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
TIMING OF THIS BILL. AND I
THOUGHT I WOULD JUST SHARE
SOMETHING.
AND I THINK IT WAS VERY TIMELY.
WHICH WAS BUSTER POSEY IS HOME
RUN. ANTI THE GRAND THREE TO
THREE. AT IN THE FIFTH INNING.
I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK A
GIANTS FAN BUT I DO HOPE THAT
THE DODGERS FANS HERE'S CAN ALSO
SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA.
THEY'RE PLAYING ARIZONA.
IT MORE TIMELY WITH MCCUTCHEON'S
HAD AT THE END TO WIN THE GAME.
THAT'S RIGHT.
MISTER LACKEY ARE YOU MAKING
WAVES.
I HAVE NO COMMENT.
BUT I THINK IT IDEA NO COMMENT
OKAY I'D LIKE TO US IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT MOTION FOR THIS.
SOME A RECRUITING.
A SECOND BY MY.
GIANTS FAN.
OKAY.
I JUST WANT COME I I'M GLAD THE
SUPERSTRUCTURE FINANCING IS WE
ARE WORKING WITH THAT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A STRUGGLE
FOR MANY PEOPLE TO TRY TO USE IT
AND I'M GLAD THAT SOMEONE THAT I
KNOW THAT IT'S A GOT SUCH A
GREAT PROJECT. TO BE ABLE TO
MAYBE LEVERAGE UP FUNDS FOR
OTHER PROJECTS ARE ADDITIONAL
MONEY SO. CONGRATULATIONS I'M
I'M HOGAN SUING AT THE SUIT FOR
A BET IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT
YOUR CITY'S BEAUTIFUL IT
EVERYBODY WHEN THEY THINK OF
CALIFORNIA THE THE THINKER
SURFER OR YOUR FROM THE GOLDEN
GATE.
SO.
WITHOUT I WILL SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY.
MUCH APPRECIATED.
REJECTED CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
PROTECT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY
AYE AGAR CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
LUPO.
BILLS AT SEVEN ZERO REGULATION
RECOMMENDED CHAIR THINKING ALL
HAVE A GREAT DAY FIGURES.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN THAT IS
RODRIGUEZ SO YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ HERE.
OKAY WHEN WE MOVE ON TO ITEM.
NINE AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
NINE GIPSON.
WELCOME MR GIPSON THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE WHICH
SEEKS TO IMPROVE WATER SERVICES
FOR CALIFORNIA'S.
MANY CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVED THEIR
DRINKING WATER FROM SMALL PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE DIFFICULT
TO MAINTAIN.
THE THESE TROUBLE SYSTEMS OFTEN
LACK RESOURCES TO FUND THE
ONGOING COSTS AND MAINTENANCE OF
OTHER LIKE OTHER.
WATER AGENCIES AND ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE TO OPERATE.
SMALL TROUBLED WATER SYSTEMS CAN
BE OVERCOME.
CAN OVERCOME THESE CHALLENGES
BY CONSOLIDATING WITH
NEIGHBORING SYSTEMS CONSOLIDATED
WATER SYSTEMS CAN SHARE COSTS
AND PROVIDE BETTER WATER
SERVICE.
THROUGH CONNIE OF SCALE.
ALTHOUGH SOME CITIES.
WE WANT TO VOLUNTARILY I'M
CONSOLIDATE THEIR TROUBLED WATER
SYSTEM THERE ARE BARRIERS TO
CONSOLIDATION.
ONE VARIAS THAT IS COSTLY
THE COST OF HOLDING A FULL BLOWN
ELECTION TO APPROVE THE SALE OF
A SMALL PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
UNDER EXISTING LAW EVEN IF THE
CITY HAS A WATER SYSTEM WITH
ONLY TEN SERVICE CONNECTIONS A
COMPLETE ELECTION WOULD BE.
NEEDED BEFORE THE SYSTEM COULD
BE SOLD WHILE THE COST TO HOLD
AN ELECTION ON MAY NOT BE
SIGNIFICANT FOR LARGER CITIES.
ARE THEY CAN BE COSTLY AND VERY
EXPENSIVE TO TAXPAYERS IN
SMALLER COMMUNITIES THEREFORE
THIS BILL WILL SEEK TO MODIFY
THE ELECTION REQUIREMENT AND
ALLOW CITIES. TO SELL THEIR
SMALL.
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS IF IT IS
IN THE BEST INTERESTS ARM OF
THAT PARTICULAR COMMUNITY. OF
THESE CHANGES WILL PROVIDE MORE
CALIFORNIANS WITH CLEANER AND
SAFER DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE I HAVE MISTER
HAWK HERE.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA WATER SO CA
SEEN WHO WILL.
INTRODUCE HIMSELF AS WELL AS
PROVIDES SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
FOR THE BILL.
I'M.
MADAM CHAIR NOT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MY NAME'S JACK HAWKS.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
WATER SOCIAIS XIN.
ONE I THINK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
HIS BILL WILL ADD ANOTHER ARROW
TO THE QUIVER.
OF THE STATE'S.
CAN WATER UTILITY CONSOLIDATION
PROGRAM.
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE IT
WILL HELP THE SMALL MUNICIPAL
WATER SYSTEMS. THAT ARE IN.
HAVING A SIGNIFICANT DIFFICULTY
IN THAT MAINTAINING KEEPING UP
THEIR SYSTEMS AND.
AND.
MAKING A NEEDED NEW INVESTMENTS
AND TRYING TO KEEP THEIR RATES
DOWN.
AND THE.
THIS WITH THE CONSOLIDATION IN
THIS STATE WITH THE POLICY WITH
THE STATE'S POLICY IT NEEDS
OPTION MELODY IN THIS BILL. IS A
DEFINITELY PROVIDING ONE OF
THOSE THAT THAT NEEDED OPTIONS.
BUT THE BEST NEWS IS THAT FOR
THEIR CUSTOMERS OF A A TROUBLED
SMALL SYSTEM THAT GET
CONSOLIDATED NOT ONLY WILL THEY
GET WATER UP TO STANDARDS BUT
THERE THE SIMPSON'S WILL BE UP
TO STANDARD. AND.
THEY.
ECONOMIES OF SCALE.
POINT THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST MADE IS IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN THIS WHOLE
CONSOLIDATION EFFORTS SO.
AND.
COULD I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE.
A CONSULTANT ON THE.
ANALYSIS HE'S GOT IT EXACTLY
RIGHT SO.
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS AND.
WE.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SOARING WILL ALSO
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
THE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION FROM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA SECOND
BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON.
OR CHECK TO CLOSE.
WELL I HAVE A QUESTION. MY OKAY
WHICH OF GO AHEAD.
THE BILL STATES THE CITY.
AND I'M WONDERING IF IT'S JUST A
IN ORDER AGENTS.
SAID THERE'S A CITY THAT HAS ITS
OWN WATER DISTRICT IN A VERY
SMALL.
WATER AGENCY.
COULD THE CITY WITH SIDE WITHIN.
YES WHAT'S WITHIN THE GENERAL
PLAN AREA YES SOME OF IT WITHIN
THE CITY LIMITS THAT'S CORRECT
SO THIS.
COULD THE CITY COUNCIL BY FOUR
OUT OF FIVE COUNCIL MEMBERS
VOTE.
TO.
CONSOLIDATE WITH THE SMALL WATER
AGENCY THAT'S PART OF THE CITY
ABSOLUTE BUT NOT ONLY BECAUSE
THE CITY HAS ITS OWN WATER
DISTRICT.
YES RIGHT.
THAT IS CORRECT THAT THE IDEA SO
WHAT IF THESE.
I'M SORRY TO ASK THIS QUESTION
OF AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE I HAVE THE
SCENARIO. WHAT IF THE SMALL
WATER DISTRICT DOES NOT ONE TO
BE CONSOLIDATED?
NO THIS KNOW THIS I MEAN I'M
SORRY SORRY YOU GOT IT BECAUSE.
IT.
YOU WANT TO THE FIRST KNUCKLE.
YEAH SO THIS IS ONLY WITH
WILLING PARTIES.
THIS ONE ENFORCE ANY OF PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE WATER SYSTEM TO
CONSOLIDATE FORCEFULLY IT'S
STRICTLY BETWEEN VOLUNTARY
WILLING PARTIES.
CONCENTRIC YEAH I THINK THAT'S
WHERE.
NO BECAUSE THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
SAYS THE CITY IF THOUSAND
INDICATING.
RIGHT TO SEPARATE STATE AND THEY
THINK THE CITY'S GOVERNING BODY.
WOULD HAVE TO PASS A RESOLUTION
AND FIRST FIND IT IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
THAT THE IS THE SYSTEM.
IS.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO PUT IN
POSITION OF BEING A.
CONSOLIDATED WITH ANOTHER SO.
RIGHT CONSENTING PARTIES I
GUESS IS THE BEST WAY HAD THE
SHORT AND WAITED. TO EXPLAIN
THIS. INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO AGREE
YEAH.
MY.
I MIGHT LIKE TO TAKE MY OFF
AGAIN I'M SORRY. I THINK I'M
JUST GONNA LAY OFF RIGHT NOW AND
THE.
SO WE HAVE A SUCH A LIE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
SO I'VE I'VE RUSHED YOU ARE YOU
OKAY. DOMINGUEZ. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND SO
I'M I APPRECIATE YOU TO ITS
INTRODUCING THIS BILL MISTER
GIBSON THERE'S NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT THAN MAKING SURE
CALIFORNIA SAFE QUALITY CLEAN
DRINKING WATER SUPPLY FOR
BRINGING THAT FORWARD. AND WITH
THAT I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL
THANK YOU.
JUST SIMPLICITY SAY THAT AGAIN
THIS WILL HELP.
THE GENERAL COMMUNITY AS WELL
AS CALIFORNIA PROVIDE GOOD.
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER WE
HAVE SOME SMALL AGENCIES ARE
STRUGGLING WHO WANT TO SURRENDER
AND THIS OF COURSE HELPS OF
THOSE SMALL AGENCIES AND ALSO
THOSE COMMUNITIES PROVIDING GOOD
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER TO
CALIFORNIA SO. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I BUILT.
DETECTIVE FARRELL THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR CURRY AYE AGUIAR CURRY
AYE WALDRON.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I'VE CABALLERO COOLEY
COOLEY AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
BILLS AT SIX ZERO INFO REALLY GO
BACK TO ITEM NUMBER TEN.
RODRIQUEZ AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN AT THE
CITY OF MONCLER AS A VOTING
MEMBER.
OF THE METRO PHOTO GOAL LIKE
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
IN DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THE CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY BROKE
GROUND TO EXTEND THE GOAL LINE
INTO THE CITY MONCLER WHICH IS
IN MY DISTRICT.
FOR MY COMMUNITY THE GOAL LINE
MEANS MORE JOBS MORE DEVELOPMENT
AND FEWER CARS ON THE ROAD IN A
REGION THAT SUFFERS FROM.
SOME OF THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN
THE NATION.
NOW THAT THE PROJECT IS MOVING
FORWARD. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THE CITY AMONG HER HAVE A VOTING
SEAT ON THE CONSTRUCTION
AUTHORITY BOARD.
AS YOU WILL HEAR FROM COUNCIL
MEMBER BILL ROUTE THE CITY OF
MONTCLAIR HAS INVESTED
SIGNIFICANT TIME AND MONEY
PREPARING FOR THE GOLD LINE.
CITY MARKER HAS BEEN A
CONTINUOUS SUPPORT OF THE GOAL
LINE. AND IS THE ONLY CITY IN
THE SOMEBODY ON COUNTY AFFECTED
BY THE PROJECT.
ADDING THEM AS A VOTING MEMBER
TO THE BOARD IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO AND NOW IS THE RIGHT TIME.
HERE WITH ME TO TO FIND SUPPORT.
IS MARKER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
BILL ROOM.
BOB.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ FOR
THIS.
BILL.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN.
THE CITY OF MONTCLAIR.
TRULY BELIEVES.
AND THE GOLD LINE.
AND MASS TRANSIT.
WE BELIEVE IN THIS SO MUCH THAT
WE'VE DECIDED.
AND HAD ADVANCED.
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
METRO GOLD LINE FOOTHILL
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY.
THIS WAS DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
WITH ADVANCEDCONCEPTUAL
ENGINEERING.
AND CONSULTING WORK.
AND IN TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT WITH
ANY LOCAL CITY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IS NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT
SOME.
ADDITIONALLY AS A CITY.
WE'VE REZONED AN AREA DIRECTLY
AROUND THE TRANSIT CENTER.
WITH A GOLD LINE.
HOPEFULLY PASS THROUGH.
YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE OF TRANSIT
ORIENTED.
DEVELOPMENT AT MUCH HIGHER
DENSITIES.
THESE DENSITIES ON AVERAGE OR
THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY UNITS.
ACRE.
THEY FULLY EMBRACE TRANSIT
ORIENTED PRINCIPLES.
MIXED USE PRINCIPLES.
AND.
BUILT INTO THEM.
GOOD ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP
WE BELIEVE THAT ALL OF THAT TIES
TOGETHER.
BECAUSE OF THIS.
THERE'S BEEN OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS EXPENDED BETWEEN
THE CITY OF MONTCLAIR.
AND THE DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY.
I'M LAND IMPROVEMENT.
I ACQUISITION STUDIES I'VE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT.
AND IN NEW CONSTRUCTION.
TIFFANY.
THIS IS PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR JOBS
FOR BUSINESS PEOPLE TO LOCATE
AND FOR PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY MOVE
CLOSE.
TO A TRANSIT
STATION.
THE GOAL LINE IS VITAL TO
MONTCLAIR AND FOR THE REGION.
BUT ESPECIALLY FOR A LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES WHO NEED SAFE.
RELIABLE.
COST EFFECTIVE TRANSPORTATION
TO HELP THE ACCESS.
JOBS
EDUCATIONAL AS WELL AS CULTURAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
ACROSS THE AREA.
WE DO HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
WILL ADVANCE THIS BILL AND IF AT
ANYTIME YOU SHOULD NEED. ANY
QUESTIONS OR NEED ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION I'M MORE THAN HAPPY.
TO PROVIDE IT.
WE DO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE TRULY HOPE THAT THIS BILL
WILL PASS THANK YOU.
ALL THE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS.
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR NEEDS
ASSOCIATES FOR THE METRO GOLD
LINE FOOTHILL EXTENSION
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE FIRST
OF ALL WE DO APPRECIATE THE ON
GOING SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLYMAN
RODRIGUEZ AND THE CITY OF
MONTCLAIR FOR THE PROJECT IS
THEY'VE OUTLINED. HOWEVER WE
DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT SOLUTION ESPECIALLY AT
THIS TIME.
JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE GOLD
MINE THE GOLD LINE IS A SPECIAL
PURPOSE PUBLIC AGENCY. THAT WAS
CREATED FOR THE SINGLE PURPOSE
OF BUILDING A LIGHT RAIL SYSTEM
IN THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY.
THEY'VE COMPLETED THE LOOK PHASE
ONE OF THE PROJECT FROM DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES TO PASADENA. THEY'VE
COMPLETED PHASE TWO OF THE
PROJECT FROM PASADENA TO OF
SOUSA. ANOTHER EMBARKING ON
PHASE THREE OF THE PROJECT HAS
BEEN OUTLINED BY ASSEMBLYMAN
RODRIGUEZ.
THE EXTENSION IS OF ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS PROJECT
WITH THE TERMINUS IN MONTCLAIR.
ONCE THE GOLD LINE FINISHES
CONSTRUCTION THEY TURN OVER
OPERATIONS TO LA METRO AND ONLY
METROS ARE FUNDING PARTNER FOR
THE PROJECT.
WE HAVE THREE ISSUES WITH THIS
BILL ONE OF THEM IN THE FIRST OF
THEM. IS THAT WE THINK THAT THE
BILL WOULD PROVIDE
DISPROPORTIONATE REPRESENTATION
TO ASSEMBLE MEDINA COUNTY.
THE GOLD MINE CURRENTLY HAS FIVE
VOTING MEMBERS
AND FOR NON VOTING MEMBERS.
WITH THE EXTENSION TO MONTCLAIR
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE PROJECT
IN SYMBOL MEDINA WILL BE SIX
PERCENT OF THE PROJECT.
HOWEVER ONE OF THE.
VOTING MEMBERS CURRENTLY IS FROM
SIMBA MEDINA COUNTY SO THEY'VE
CURRENTLY GOT TODAY THE TWENTY
PERCENT VOTE ON THE BOARD. THIS
WOULD INCREASE THAT THIRTY THREE
PERCENT ON THE BOARD.
I'M ALSO CURRENTLY TODAY ONE OF
THE NON VOTING MEMBERS IS FROM
SAM OR DID YOU KNOW COUNTY.
WE THINK THAT THE GOLD LINES
DONE A GOOD JOB OF REPRESENTING
THE INTERESTS OF SAMBOR MEDINA
COUNTY IN THEIR COMMITTED TO
GOING TO MONTCLAIR. HOME AND
WE'VE OUTLINED THAT AS I'VE
MENTIONED.
ALSO WE FEEL THAT THE BILL
COULD POTENTIALLY PROVIDE SOME
SIGNIFICANT.
.
ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO THE PROJECT
THE GOAL LINE HIS PRE QUALIFIED
A DESIGN BUILD CONTRACTORS WERE
IN THE PROCESS OF GOING OUT TO
BID FOR THAT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THOSE
CONTRACTORS ARE UNSURE OF WHAT
THEY'RE BIDDING ON OR WHAT THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD IS WERE
CONCERNED THAT MIGHT LEAD TO.
ADDITIONAL RISK TO THE PROJECT
AND THAT ADDITIONAL MITT RISK
COULD.
POTENTIALLY HAVE THE IMPACT OF
NOT HAVING ENOUGH MONEY TO GO TO
MONK CLEAR WHICH IS WHAT WE ALL
WANT TO DO IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND THEN FINALLY WE THINK THAT
THE BILL'S PRE MATURITY HER
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OUTLINED THIS
PRETTY WELL.
SO FAR WELL MONK CLEAR HAS PUT
UP SOME MONEY FOR PLANNING
THERE'S NO FINANCIAL COMMITMENT
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION ASPECTS OF
THE PROJECT WE THINK THAT UNTIL
THERE'S A.
BETTER FINANCIAL AGREEMENT ON
GOING INTO A SYMBOL MEDINA
COUNTY IT'S PREMATURE TO THE.
AND ADD ADDITIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES TO THE BOARD AND
SO FOR THOSE THREE REASONS WERE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M ISRAEL
WILL FUND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAN MEDINA TRANSPORTATION
SOME REAL COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY.  OUR AGENCY HAS
TAKEN AND OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN.
WHAT WE FULLY SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ IS EFFORTS TO ADD THE
CITY OF MONTCLAIR'S VOICE TO THE
BOARD? AND WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
OUR VOICE IS A VOTING MEMBER IS
EQUALLY IF NOT MORE SIGNIFICANT.
THE CONVERSION OF OUR CURRENT EX
OFFICIO NONVOTING SEAT TO THE
GOAL LINE CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY
IS CRITICAL TO PROVIDING INPUT
ON ITEMS AFFECTING SAMBAR MEDINA
COUNTY.
AS WE ARE PROJECTED TO
CONTRIBUTE MORE THAN EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT OF THE PROJECT.
AND THEN ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
ONGOING CONTRIBUTE APPROXIMATELY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE IN
PERPETUITY.
THE CURRENT MAKE UP OF THE GOAL
LINE CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY
PASADENA SOUTH PASADENA LOS
ANGELES LA METRO IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS.
HAVE DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY
OVER A PROJECT THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN CONSTRUCTED THROUGH THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AND WILL UNLESS MODIFIED HAVE
THE SAME AUTHORITY OVER THE
PHASE OF THE PROJECT THAT HIS
PROPOSED TO BE CONSTRUCTED
THROUGH GLENDORA SAN DEMI'S LA
VERNE POMONA CLAREMONT. AND
MONTCLAIR.
LIKE LOS ANGELES AND WOULD YOU
KNOW COUNTY IS A SELF HELP
COUNTY.
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADMITTING A BIT
MINISTERING A LOCAL SALES TAX
DEDICATED TO TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENT IN THE COUNTY.
AND LIKE LOS ANGELES THE
TAXPAYERS OF SAMBOR TO DINO
COUNTY DESERVE REPRESENTATION AS
A VOTING MEMBER. HOW ON THE
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY TO ENSURE
THAT THE FUNDING CONTRIBUTED TO
THE PROJECT IS USED IN A MANNER
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
LOCAL SALES TAX MEASURE?
WE WOULD URGE A NO VOTE TODAY
UNLESS THE BILL AS AMENDED TO
ADD THIS AMBER TO DINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IS ANYONE ELSE IN.
A PROPOSITION OF THE SPILL.
BAKE YOU CURE US ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PASADENA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION FOR SOME OF THE
REASONS THAT BEEN PREVIOUSLY
STATED.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE.
.
YES MR UP VOEPEL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST A QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE.
ARE YOU WILLING TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENT.
BECAUSE THEY ONE ANOTHER ACTIVE
BOARD MEMBER THAT'S WHERE I
UNDERSTAND IT IS THAT CORRECT.
CORRECT IF I MAY YEAH NAM MADAM
CHAIR. I'M GOING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO LOOK TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE AND AND THAT THAT
OTHER SEAT LIKE THAT SAID YEAH.
THAT'S GOING AND SOMEBODY NO
COUNTY.
BUT SOMETIMES I LOOK BACK THIS
PROJECT IT'S BEEN PRETTY MUCH
TALKED ABOUT THE LAST FORTY FIVE
YEARS.
AND NEVER ONCE THAT I'VE BEEN IN
AN OFFICE HAVE THEY'VE EVER
APPROACHED ME TO BE ON THE BOARD
RIGHT SINCE WE ALL KNEW THIS WAS
COMING. I'VE NEVER HAD ANY
DISCUSSION WITH THAT ALL OF A
SUDDEN I HAVE THIS BILL FOR TWO.
AT THE CITY OF MONTCLAIR WOULD
JUST THIS NEXT PHASE OF WORKING
TO END. AND NOW I'M I'M GETTING
THERE THEIR.
INTEREST AND NOW OPPOSITION THE
LAST THIRD THEY'RE NOT THAT SHE
THE TABLE WHICH. I WISH TO
DISCUSS WHAT HAPPENED SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER.
BUT ALSO LIKE THEIR COMMITMENT
FROM THE COUNTY OF SOMEBODY KNOW
THAT THAT'S NOT JUST STOP AT
MONTCLAIR LET'S CONTINUE THIS
PROJECT. FURTHER INTO SOMEBODY
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A SEAT AT THE
BOARD IF
IT'S ONLY ONE MILE INTO THE
COUNTY.
AND I'M SORRY BUT I DON'T.
COME UP WITH A PRICE TAG ON IT
THE EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S GOING TO BE IN SUMMER
DINO.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S THE
WAY IT'S WORKED OUT IT'S ONLY
ONE MILE INTO THE COUNTY AND IF
I CAN GET COMMITMENT FROM
SOMEBODY IN A COUNTY THAT. LET'S
CONTINUE MOVING THIS PROJECT
ALONG FURTHER AT DECEMBER DINO
COUNTY BY ALL MEANS I'M I'M
WILLING TO WORK WITH THEM ON
ADDING THAT SEE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR ONE LAST
COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS ONLY GOING
IN ONE MILE.
I WILL TRUST YOUR VIEW OF IT
AND SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BOOK
READING.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND WE NEED A SECOND.
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
SOME WALDRON SECONDS I'M
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY. A WOULD
YOU LIKE TO A CLOSE.
MEMBERS ARE STRICTLY ASK DR VOTE
AS WE LOOK TO ADD A DOSE
ADDITIONAL MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION AND SANDRA VALLEY
THANK YOU.
SO.
YOU NOT TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT ONE
AT LENGTH IN THIS MONTH ALSO I
HAVE CONCERN BECAUSE LOCAL
INTERESTED PARTIES AREN'T ABLE
TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT AND HOW
BEST MOVE FORWARD. AND I'M
SYMPATHETIC TO THE RESERVATIONS
OF THE OPPOSITION.
I'M GOING TO MOVE THE BILL FOR
TODAY WITH THE HOPE THAT
CONCERNS WILL BE ADDRESSED
BEFORE IT REACHES THE FLOOR BUT
I RESERVE MY RIGHT TO VOTE. KNOW
IF THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR CURRY.
I AGAR CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM NOT VOTING CABALLERO
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I GRAYSON. LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
BILLS.
RESULT SIX ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND SOME REMEMBER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WILL. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT SYRIA
MAYES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MISTER MAYNES.
THANK YOU VENTURE IN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN.
WOULD GIVE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
REGIONAL PARK IN OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT THE SAME PURCHASING
POWER AS OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
I TO THE JURISDICTION OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS
AT THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE NEED
TO INCREASE THE GENERAL MANAGERS
PURCHASING LIMIT TO MATCH OTHER
COUNTY DIVISION HAD LIMITS.
OVER TIME COST INCREASES HAVE
EFFECTIVELY REDUCED THE
DISTRICTS PURCHASING POWER.
INCREASING THE NO BID PURCHASING
AUTHORITY TO FIFTY THOUSAND
COMPENSATES FOR THE RISING
GENERAL COSTS OF THE DISTRICT.
I WOULD BETTER SUPPORT THE
DISTRICT'S MISSION BY
ELIMINATING ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
FOR SMALL PROJECTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
REPRESENTATIVES HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS AND. I
CAN HELP ANSWERQUESTIONS AS
WELL FATE WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M ELIZABETH HAS BEEN US ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE A COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. RIFF CHO
PARKS AS IT'S AFFECTIONATELY
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS A
DEPENDENT HOW SPECIAL DISTRICT
IN THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES OFFERING THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY AND ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT. I HAVE.
WITH ME TODAY MAKING GOMEZ
WHO'S THE FINANCE MANAGER OF THE
PERKS DISTRICT AND SHE CAN SPEAK
TO SOME OF THE SPECIFICS THANK
YOU.
BOTH OF.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MEGAN GMEZ
I AM THE FISCAL MANAGER FOR
RIVERSIDE COUNTY REGIONAL PARK
AND OPEN SPACE DISTRICT.
AND.
AS MENTIONED WERE KNOWN AS REV
CHO PARKS
SO I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHO WE ARE AND WHY WE
ARE MAKING THIS REQUEST.
FIRST I COUNTY PARKS WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
THROUGH THE VOTERS APPROVAL. AND
OUR MISSION IS TO ACQUIRE
PROTECT DEVELOP MANAGE AND
INTERPRET FOR THE INSPIRATION
USE AND ENJOYMENT OF ALL PEOPLE
IT WELL BALLOT SYSTEM OF PARK
RELATED PLACES. OF.
OUTSTANDING SCENIC RECREATIONAL
AND HISTORIC IMPORTANCE.
OUR SYSTEM FEATURES OVER SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES THAT
INCLUDES REGIONAL PARKS THAT
HAVE CAMPING AND FISHING AND
OTHER AMENITIES.
WE ALSO HAVE HISTORIC SITES
ECOLOGICAL RESERVES A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE MILES OF TRAILS
AND COUNTING. AT A STATE OF THE
ART SPORTS PERKY AND ALSO
ACTIVELY MANAGED ECOLOGICAL
HABITATS IN ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE AREAS. ON A TWENTY
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE WERE RECEIVED
ACCREDITATION OF A NATIONAL
STATUS FROM CAP ROW WHICH IS
KEY.
OTHER COMMISSION FOR
ACCREDITATION OF PARK AND
RECREATION AGENCIES
A FOR DEMONSTRATING THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF STANDARDS IN ETHICAL
AND PERFORM OF PROFESSIONAL
PRACTICES. IN THE DELIVERY OF
PARK AND REC PROGRAMS.
I WE'RE THE SECOND AGENCY IN
CALIFORNIA BEHIND THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO TO RECEIVE THIS
NATIONAL ACCREDITATION. AND THE
FIRST COUNTY IN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA TO RECEIVE THE HONOR.
SO WE HOLD OURSELVES TO VERY
HIGH STANDARDS AND WE STRIVE TO
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH SUPERIOR
PARKS AND SERVICES.
SO NOW ON TO THE DETAILS AS TO
WHY WE'RE REQUESTING.
THIS INCREASE OUR PURCHASING
POWER.
THE NRP A WHICH IS THE NATIONAL
PARK AND RECREATION AGENCY THEY
PUBLISH AN ANNUAL AGENCY YOU
PERFORMANCE REVIEW REPORTS THAT
COMPILES STATISTICS THAT HAVE
BEEN VOLUNTARILY SUBMITTED BY.
PARK AND REC AGENCIES ALL ACROSS
THE NATION AND REPORTS ON TRENDS
AND PLUS A SPECIFIC STATISTICS
AND STANDARDS.
THE RECENTLY RELEASED TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORTS.
REPORTED THAT THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE OPERATING EXPENDITURES
FOR PARKS AND REC AGENCIES IS
AROUND THREE POINT THREE
MILLION.
RIFF CHO PARKS IS THAT EIGHTEEN
WHICH IS SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
AND THERE ARE SEVEN OTHER
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES THAT ARE
COMPARABLE TO OURS.
AND HERE'S WHERE THE INTERESTING
STATISTICS COME INTO PLAY.
AND IT RELATES TO OPERATING
EXPENDITURES PER CAPITA.
THE OTHER CALIFORNIA AGENCIES
WHO REPORTED THEIR EXPENDITURES
ARE SPENDING ON AVERAGE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX DOLLARS
FOR EVERY TEN THOUSAND OF THEIR
CITIZENS.
RIFF CHO PARKS WE HAVE ONLY
EIGHT DOLLARS PER TEN THOUSAND
CITIZENS.
SO THAT RIGHT THERE SHOULD SHOW
YOU THAT WE'RE OPERATING ON A
SHOE
STRING BUDGETS BUT YET WE'RE
STILL AN AWARD WINNING AND
NATIONALLY CREDITED AGENCY.
ADDITIONALLY OF THE EIGHTEEN
MILLION THAT WE HAVE TO SPEND
EACH YEAR OF FORTY SEVEN PERCENT
OF THAT HOUSE TO COME FROM
EARNED REVENUE. OUR PROPERTY TAX
INCREMENT ONLY COVERS THIRTY
FOUR PERCENT OF OUR OPERATIONS
SO THE REST HAS TO BE EARNED
THROUGH USER FEES. AND THROUGH
GRANTS AND SPONSORSHIPS SO WE
REALLY HAVE TO FOCUS ON BEING
EFFICIENT AND KEEPING OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD VERY
LOW.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN WOULD GRANT OUR GENERAL
MANAGER THE AUTHORITY TO.
DO NO BID PROCUREMENT OF UP TO
FIFTY THOUSAND WHICH WOULD
DOUBLE IT FROM TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND.
WE DO A LOT OF SPECIALIZED
PROCUREMENTS WHERE WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE PUBLIC VETTING
PROCESS AND WE GENERALLY END UP
WITH MAYBE ONE VENDOR BECAUSE
DESPITE SERVICES ARE SO
SPECIALIZED.
SO THE EXTRA MINISTRY OF COST TO
DO THAT PROCESS IS MONEY THAT WE
COULD MUCH BETTER SPENT
ELSEWHERE IN OUR PARKS AND IN
OUR PROGRAMS FOR THE PUBLIC.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO I'M
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES AND A SPECIAL THANK
YOU TO SENATOR.
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES FOR.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE AND OF
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THE MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BILL
GIVENS WITH CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION HOW WELL
THIS ISN'T ONE OF OUR DISTRICTS.
.
WHAT THE AUTHORITY THERE BE
GRANTED UNDER THIS LEGISLATION A
SIMILAR TO WHAT'S BEEN OFFERED
TO? A FEW OF OUR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IN THE PAST OR ARE A
PART DISTRICTS.
THIS IS BEEN TO GREAT BENEFIT
TO THOSE DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE
TO.
USE THEIR LIMITED RESOURCES TO
BENEFIT THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY TENURE ANYWHERE
ELSE AND THE SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THE OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I NEED A MOTION.
THE CARRY HAVE SOME MEMBER OF
WALDRON AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA.
THE JUDGE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY.
FIRST WHY ONCE SAY THANK YOU I
LOVE OPEN SPACE I'M A BIG OPEN
SPACE FRAN.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR JUST.
I KIDS GETTING OUT THERE AND ALL
THE RECREATION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FOR.
I WILL SUPPORT A BILL TODAY.
TECHNICAL THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AGUIAR
CURRY AYE AGUIAR CURRY AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON LACKEY.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
BILLS AT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TRIP UP HERE.
NEXT WE WILL HAVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB TWO ZERO THREE FIVE
MULLIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LAST YEAR I CARRIED A
BILL WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
TO ALLOW CITIES AND COUNTIES
STATEWIDE.
CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITIES TO FIND ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THE PROMOTION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THROUGH LOCAL TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING WITHOUT
RAISING TAXES.
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AUTHORITIES
LAW VERY STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BOND COUNSEL.
AND HOUSING DEVELOPERS HAVE
ASKED FOR CLEAN UP A BILL TO
ENSURE THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITIES AND TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
CAN BE IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY.
AB TWENTY THIRTY FIVE PROVIDES
CLARITY THE TAXING ENTITIES AND
LOCAL AUDITOR CONTROLLERS ON HOW
TO ADDRESS COMPLEXITIES IN THE
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT
FRAMEWORK.
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENT
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH
CORRECTS A DRAFTING MISTAKE. AND
CLARIFIES THE INTENT OF THE BILL
AS IT RELATES TO THE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR THE GOVERNING BOARD.
OF THE AUTHORITIES AND I HAVE
HERE WITH ME TODAY MICHAEL LANE
OF THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR I YOUR CURRY.
MEMBERS MICHAEL A WITH THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE PLEASED
WE GOT SO MUCH INTEREST IN THE
BILL THAT HAD COUNTIES COME TO
US SINCE WE TRY TO SEE OTHER CAN
IMPLEMENT THIS WAS CITIES. AS
THEY GOT THE DETAILS GOT SOME
QUESTIONS WANTED WORK WITH WITH
THE CONTROLLER FOR THE COUNTIES.
WHOHAVE PROVIDED SOME
TECHNICAL MINISTER THAT YOU SEE
TODAY?
IT IN ADDITION.
JUST TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE THE
TAX INCREMENT WE'RE GOING FOR
FOR CITIES WHO WANTED TO
COOPERATE WITH COUNTIES TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. SO WE'VE BEEN
PLEASE TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS.
AND BRINGS FOUR WITH MR MULLIN
SO WE CAN GO AHEAD AND GET THIS
UP AND RUNNING AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DURING THE
NIELSEN SUPPORT.
I THINK MEN CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEEFE DONE HERE TODAY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK THANK
YOU.
JENNIFER SPEC ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU RATE THAT YOU'RE GONNA.
ALTHOUGH ANYONE IN ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
HELLO MONTHS HE WILL HAVE A
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT.
WE NEED A MOTION.
OKAY.
THE PICK WHICHEVER ONE YOU WANT
OVER HERE BUT IT'S A.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOOMS A FAIR
ENOUGH.
OKAY WHICH I TO CLOSE.
AS FOR LIVE OF GROUPTHINK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ALSO PUT THIS MORNING A BILL
TODAY I'M REALLY LIKE AFFECT
YOUR REFINING LAST YEAR'S FOR
WILL HOUSING.
AUTHORITY BILL SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH
AND I'M SURE YOU'LL FIND TO LOTS
OF THINGS AS WE GO FORWARD SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
FORWARD.
SECRETARY COLOR WORLD THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED IN RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ACT WHERE CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE GRAYSON.
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO VOEPEL.
THE POUND NO.
THE.
WILL HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE REST
OF OUR WORLD WERE SHUT ONE VOTE
OKAY.
POLICY HERE I THINK IT'S MISTER
FLORA ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED. YOU'VE BEEN SO
PATIENT.
THANK YOU MISTER FLORA THANK
YOU.
FEEL SO LONELY UP HERE.
WELL IS THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
JUST MOVE THE BILLS THAT RELY
YES RESPECT LESS RELIABLE.
OKAY THE NEW INNOCENCE APART.
IN OPPOSITION.
I DO WE HAVE ANY COMMITTEE
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE DO A MOTION THAT WE
HAVE WON. HIM OVER.
OR DID RESPECT ON.
BOY YOU GUYS ARE CREEK FLORA
ANYMORE LIKE FLORA COME IN HERE.
OKAY.
GIVE A CLOSING STATEMENT JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU I WOULD
THINK YOU.
I'M NOT SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
I WAS BE SUPPORTING THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AGUIAR CURRY. AGUIAR
CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CABALLERO
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA GLORIA AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
VOEPEL.
SINCE HOW I.
BILLS THAT IT'S ZERO THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
REALLY HAVE TO.
PRESENTERS THAT WE ARE STILL
WAITING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
WHO IS?
A GREAT WILL BE STARTING
SHORTLY.
DO AND KETCHUP VOTES RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE SINCE.
YEAH WHY DO WE GO AHEAD AND DO
THAT.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ITEM ONE AND
MAYBE SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
STEINORTH AND ITEM SIX
AB TWENTY TO FORTY NINE COOLEY.
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE CABALLERO.
ITEM TWO.
AB TWENTY THIRTY FIVE MULLIN
CABALLERO GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
ITEMS FOR AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
TWO LIVING. WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
CABALLERO
.
AB TWENTY.
ISRAEL LENT AB TWENTY THREE A I
THIRTY FIVE.
MAYBE TWENTY BY THIRTY FIVE.
WITHOUT FIVE THREE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN MAYES.
CABALLERO GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY EIGHT REYES.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTEEN RODRIGUEZ
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT CHIU. VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
ALRIGHT WILL MOVE ONE A GOOD
AFTERNOON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD WE ARE AT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
TWO WELCOME.
THINK MEDICARE AND MEMBERS SO
LET ME START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THINKING YOUR STAFF YOUR CONSOLE
TO YOUR LEFT THERE WHO'S DONE IT
DID YEOMAN'S JOB AND AND THIS
AND WE.
OF THAT LEFT.
I WOULD BE THE ROUTE LEFT MY
LEFT.
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'VE
MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY TO IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT SIMPLY
CLARIFIES COAST LIFE SUPPORT
DISTRICTS ENABLING LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
OFFER VITAL URGENT CARE
SERVICES.
IN A VERY REMOTE AREA OF MY
DISTRICT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AIBO.
OKAY THANK DO NO. SUPPORT GETS
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONNIE DEL GATO WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
PLEASED TO BE HERE.
TO ENSURE THAT THAT COMMUNITIES
THAT GET THE ESSENTIAL.
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED FOR
HEALTHCARE SERVICES BEGAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SAYING NONE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM. OF IT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
BLUEFIN PROJECT CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR A VOTE
OKAY WITH THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
HAVE YOU MEMORY A BREACH OF
AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF
WORKER OF MINE TO ENSURE LEFT GO
OVERSIGHT OF OVER THE DISTRICT
IMPORTANT MEDICAL SERVICE SIDE.
SERVICES IT PROVIDES OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITHOUT I WAS SUPPORTING A BILL.
OKAY SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR CURRY. AGUIAR CURRY AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I COPY ZERO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL HIGH.
BILLS THAT EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MUCH APPRECIATED.
WE HAVE ONE LAST BILL TO HEAR
WHICH WOULD BE ITEM FOURTEEN US
HIS VIEWS THAT. WILL BE.
FIFTEEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
HAVE RECALLED HIM.
THANK YOU
.
AFTER THE VOTE.
THE REST OF THE.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW.
BUT IF YOU READ ABOUT IT.
PRODUCT.
DO YOU.
CONTINUOUS RECORDING FOR THE
CONCERNS.
I DON'T THINK I PROJECTS WE HAVE
GOING FOR.
PORTANTINO.
HOW ABOUT?
PERHAPS YOU THINK.
I JUST AGREEMENT CHAIR OF.
I SHOULD PROBABLY.
I DON'T KNOW.
YEAH I AGREE.
BECAUSE OF THAT
I THINK.
STREETS CALM THE MIND.
THANKS VERY MUCH YOU.
BUT MY.
SO NO LONGER DRIVE JUST.
RIGHT.
YOU WOULD BE DOING.
NO I ALREADY DID MONDAY.
SHORTER THIS ONE SHORT FOR
NO OF OUR.
.
YES.
YEAH IT'S PRETTY GOOD. THEN
BECAUSE LILIES LILIES SHE GOES
CRAZY.
BECAUSE.
LEARN YOUR PROGRAM
IT'S.
YEAH. NORTH ON
.
BUT PAUL.
IT'S IS VOTE.
ITEM ONE A. B. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
STEINORTH CONSENT AND ITEM SIX
AB TWENTY TO FORTY NINE. COOLEY
CONSENT.
CABALLERO AYE CABALLERO AYE.
ITEM TO AB TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
MULLIN.
CABALLERO IT WITHIN AMEND PASSED
WITHIN THE MEN.
I COVER ERA I.
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY SIX TO FIVE
DO PASS AS AMENDED CABALLERO
AYE.
CABALLERO I'VE.
ITEM FOUR.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY TWO LEVINE
DO PASS AS AMENDED CABALLERO AYE
AYE COMPARE AYE.
ITEM FIVE.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN MAYES
CABALLERO AYE COMPARE AYE.
ITEM SEVEN.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY TWO DO PASS
AS AMENDED CABALLERO AYE AYE
COMPARE AYE.
ITEM EIGHT.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY EIGHT REYES
TO BASS AS AMENDED CABALLERO I
COME HERE I.
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
NINE GIPSON.
CABALLERO. AYE.
COME HERE I.
ITEM TEN. AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN RODRIGUEZ.
CABALLERO I COME HERE I.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY ONE.
CABALLERO I CAREER AYE TRAIN AND
TWELVE. AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
EIGHT CHIU.
CABALLERO AYE CAREER I.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT CLERK.
DO PASS AS AMENDED CABALLERO AYE
COMPARE AYE.
ITEM FOR FOURTEEN A BETWEEN SIX
HUNDRED FLORA.
CABALLERO AND I COME HERE I.
OKAY WELCOME MISTER GRAY WE ARE
ON ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN.
NO.
HAD TO SEE IT ONCE TODAY.
MUZZLE START NOW.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
THREE PROVIDES A TWENTY FOUR
MONTH EXTENSION FOR TENTATIVE
TRACK. AND PARCEL MAPS RELATED
TO HOUSING IN ECONOMICALLY
DEPRESSED COUNTIES OUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE BELL SECOND.
OKAY WE HAVE.
WOULD SEE AS ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
YEAH WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING A BILL
TODAY MISS I DRANK. AND
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. MOTION
IS DO PASSIVE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AGUIAR
CURRY. AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I COPY HERO.
CABALLERO AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
GLORIA.
GLORIA I GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
BILLS OUT NINE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE ADVENTURE
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THERE IS NO.
BUT I HIT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.
WE TAKE THIS FROM THE US DEBUTED
YEAH.
PHONE